NATO has warned that Vladimir Putin has
deployed a submarine carrying the
Poseidon tsunami bomb now this is not to
imply that they're planning on using it
on Western Nations or anything like that
but this is a bomb that can create
apparently create a radioactive tsunami
when somebody what are you doing here
Ian prepping for the show yeah I turned
that about five minutes too late too
late so this is a tsunami bomb it is
being tested and they don't believe it
could be the weapon can be deployed
until 2027 but they apparently have it
they need to try it and the question is
if they need to test it why not just
test it now the other bigger issue is
that there's a train scene moving in
satellite imagery which which carries
the crew for nuclear rocketry and other
things like that so they do believe that
Vladimir Putin is advancing the
mobilization of nuclear weapons and I I
just gotta say you know these people who
think it can't happen maybe maybe it's
it's optimism maybe it's normalcy bias
but Vladimir Putin does not seem like
the kind of guy who wants to lose or
will let the West steamroll him and now
it looks like NATO is stepping ever
closer to actively being I mean we know
they're involved in the war we know NATO
us everybody it's it's this you know
multi-front War but they're getting
close to actually just saying okay we're
here so Elon Musk goes on Twitter and
says we need to negotiate peace the The
Washington Post editorial board says we
need to stop this I mean this is the
Washington Post and of course Ukrainian
officials including zelenski himself
basically rag on Elon Musk like no these
people are dragging us into World War
Three it's insane so we'll talk about
that we got a couple other stories we've
got Kanye West and Candace Owens
apparently wore White lives matter
shirts
so uh well that's a thing and then we
have this uh this cultural story we have
um Billy eichner's gay rom-com Bros
bombed and apparently it's because of
homophobia or something so sure we'll
talk about that stuff before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member to
support our work as a member you'll get
access to the uncensored members only
show Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
we're gonna have one of those coming up
for you tonight and all our other shows
like the cast Castle Vlog Tales from the
inverted world and you're supporting our
journalists we have a decent amount
we're hiring more and we're only able to
have them staffed because you guys are
members that's how we make the whole
ship run so smash that like button right
now if you haven't already subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Benny Johnson
what's up great to be here who are a
huge fan for a long time oh appreciate
it man host of the Benny show uh podcast
host of uh the betting report on Newsmax
uh Turning Point USA contributor Benny
on the Block little man on the street
show and uh Nemer
right on you got attacked recently
didn't you my memes your memes guys yeah
so not actually mine so the memes of a
great couple memers uh not Paso and uh
dreyfenzor it was a tasteful meme of
Kamala Harris laughing uh to mariachi
music as a Bus full of criminal migrants
pull into her her lawn
um and we played that at the University
of Iowa my alma mater
um and a uh very sad person went and
attacked the projector I don't know if
this person if Panasonic hurt this man
uh at one point or another uh we don't
know we do know that the left can't Meme
and now we have proven it physically we
say it a lot and that the left can't
mean but now we actually physically
manifested that the left Camp meme as
his little bird uh bird bone like Hollow
Leg like uh kick the projector went
about a foot uh Smash It On The Ground
and they went running out screaming that
we were racist didn't he he did get
arrested uh fifth degree misdemeanor
assault
um spent the night in jail but nothing
can be more painful than what waking up
and finding that you yourself are the
meme in the morning and so the internet
was just filled with glorious glorious
waterfall of memes of this guy kicking
uh the the favorite one was definitely
the replacement of the meme we were
playing with uh very racist things that
Joe Biden has said throughout his career
like if you don't vote for me uh you're
not black yeah and so on and so forth
Joe Biden saying that you're you know
that that uh Mexicans or tacos and so on
well all right man should be fun we also
have Mr Lucid Caskey himself hey guys
I'm not kicked out of this show yeah not
yet uh today I'm also wearing a very
prophetic shirt that was originally
released in 2019 and became very true it
has the official Biden and Kamala logo
with them saying uh we're gonna be
arresting people for victimless crimes
that actually pretty much actually did
happen is happening to a lot of people
if you like the shirt you can get it on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
I'm still reeling from Friday Luke that
was growth
camera shut down Benny it's great to see
you man what's up uh Tim got me a gift
but this weekend he went to Cooper's
rocks in West Virginia and got me some
of these delicious gorgeous jelly beans
they're actually just rock polished
rocks yeah I used to treat them like
jelly beans when I was a kid and never
really ate one or anything you know you
were saying the left cam meme I think
angry people can't meme yes but they can
be memed which is what seems to keep
happening is these people that are angry
maybe go crazy and become revolutionary
or disenfranchise and call them leftists
or whatever you want to call them but
man when you're in a state of anger it's
impossible to make light of something
that's my experience so Ian I'm 36 years
old I was born in 1986 and you could go
back in my childhood and turn on late
night TV and you can still find them
making uh them making fun you turn on
you again Ian no no he was making weird
noises anyway yeah that was weird
continue continue continue
um making fun of the left yeah it used
to be a thing that you could do on a
Saturday Night Live right they went
really hard after Al Gore when he was
running for president you used to make
fun of people on the left and they
haven't been made fun of in corporate
media culture in a very very long time
it's been years I'll let you know ever
since Trump you're not you're no longer
allowed to make fun of these people in
this movement and I think it's very
healthy actually so science proves that
like when you're laughing together and
with each other then that actually
creates bonds and so you should be you
should want people to laugh uh at
themselves at their own political
movement at the stupidity of their own
politicians this is comedy Gold by the
way the bite Administration this should
be like the Golden Era of SNL and of
late night comedy Administration but you
can't find you can't find me a single
joke like Jimmy Fallon told a joke about
Biden and went viral among the
conservative media ecosystem because
like a guy telling a joke about Biden
right and so because they never get
laughed at they respond like this when I
play a meme for them they have never
been made fun of and so it hurts it
physically hurts they feel pain that's
right and so the soy in Rage it the
soy-filled bloodstream like goes you
know it becomes enraged and then they
just react violently uh because they
don't know what else to do yeah a lot of
people don't know this but the original
the The Incredible Hulk originally it
was a soy
well I'm here so that you can make fun
of someone on the left I'll be your
resident leftist and if you agree with
me put a one in the chat
I'm very trying to trick people it's all
about the Art of War man this feign
weakness when you're strong that's right
I appreciate this practice of The Art of
War thank you very much Ian I'm very
excited to have you Benny I'm stoked to
see what memes we get into tonight I am
also here pushing buds in the corner
let's go all right here's the story From
timcast.com Russia deploys sub-armed
with weapon of the Apocalypse the
Poseidon torpedo could destroy European
cities by creating a tsunami wave the
size of four and a half football fields
wow the sub named belgarad is that you
pronounce it has disappeared from its
harbor in the Arctic promoting NATO to
warn member countries that Russia may be
planning to test its Poseidon torpedo
which is an InterContinental
nuclear-armed nuclear-powered autonomous
weapon I think that should be prompting
NATO to warn from the countries yeah
yeah oh yeah I see there's a p it's
supposed to be prompting so uh some
people have said it's 100 Megaton a
torpedo the uh more reasonable estimates
is two megatons which is still
nightmarish apparently this this
autonomous drone torpedo has his nuclear
power it's got its own small reactor
which means it has an infinite range not
literally infinite but that it could hit
anything on the planet it could go and
just hit it
so he's deployed this uh this sub
they're saying he's going to test it and
they're not convinced that the weapon
will is actually can be used just now
somebody's it's not coming from me
that's not me either sound no nothing's
popping up
someone keeps making something from the
Mainframe no it's coming from the main
computer not the main computer we don't
have speakers on the computer somewhere
this is Bluetooth never heard that noise
before it's coming from it's coming from
Luke's face
all right so anyway back to nuclear
violation you thought about that that's
right it could be here it could be the
subject maybe so this uh this
theoretically could hit uh anywhere on
the planet now I don't know if this is
the the the big concern because it's not
been tested and I guess the estimate
here is they say it's not gonna be
operational until 2027. I suppose if
they have it and it's like partially
functional why not test it if they need
to you know what I mean like well now's
not a good time to test a weapon because
it'll look like they're preparing to
launch I I think geopolitically the the
mediocre intelligent people will be like
oh no that means they're getting
prepared to use it well this is why
which I guess they technically are this
is why the U.S like canceled a few you
know was it like Titan missile test but
what I mean is if they haven't tested it
yet why why does that matter if they
have have it and it might or might not
work they will use it if they need to
and we can flip a coin and wonder which
city is going to get wiped out a
radioactive tsunami or we can just be
like hey maybe we should stop the war
also how many of these do they have how
many autonomous weapons are available
like this is the future of modern war at
least the present day modern Wars
autonomous nuclear weapons that can take
out cities from a distance well we need
to be you know honest with ourselves we
don't know exactly what they have a lot
of the times military technology is far
behind what the general public believes
is even out there but for for the record
Russia has
6255 nuclear warheads that's that's the
recorded uh amount that of course
everyone publicly talks about but again
what we're talking about here is is a
new form of Weaponry that is going to of
course launch a nuclear weapon
underwater and launch a tsunami with
with radioactive waste onto a shoreline
this is what they're talking about I
don't know how you test these certain
types of weapon but it's not just the
submarine that we should be worrying
about Israeli intelligence is also so
documenting how Russian bombers capable
of a nuclear attack were just found near
Finland there's of course the nuclear
train that people are talking about so
it definitely does seem like Russia is
allowing a lot of its nuclear assets to
be deployed whether tested or or not we
don't know exactly what's going on here
but regardless I think this is news that
I think we should be paying more
attention to here's what people need to
understand too I'd be willing to bet
the first the first Target of any kind
of nuclear strike it's going to be
tactical nukes it's going to be nuclear
artillery so Russia will fire at a
military Target probably a shot across
the bow meaning it'll hit nothing and
then it'll be devastating and that's
them being like we're doing it then if
the war continues they'll use they'll
use uh nuclear artillery against
military targets then they'll probably
use lower yield nuclear weapons against
smaller cities it'll it'll draw up but
if it really gets to full-scale nuclear
war
then you don't need to worry about New
York dcla or Chicago you need to worry
about small towns
they're not going I would imagine Russia
is not going to Target if they're going
for a shock and awe kind of nuclear
strike against America U.S city which I
I don't think is very likely at all it's
going to be a small City what's a what's
what's a good example name a small City
can you think about Dubuque Dubuque love
you guys that's a good point it's a good
City actually Dubuque Iowa yeah yeah
that's that actually I know their
population it's probably a couple
hundred thousand maybe but this is
exactly what I mean if the people who
live in small towns think ah it's New
York ah it's DC I got anything to worry
about
if they want to cause shock and all
damage and really paralyze the economy
and the American people
going after a big city just confirms
that they feel safe we're not in the big
city we don't got anything to worry
about it would be bad it would be scary
but you know we're in the middle of
nowhere they go after Dubuque everyone
everywhere in the country is going to be
worried that's what freaks me out like I
don't know if 911 I don't know who did
it I still don't but I am not putting it
past the government to Nuke one of its
small towns or cities and blame it on
the Russians like I that's been on my
mind lately it's like a full scale 200
000 people are just of evaporated or
illiterate and then then they're and
then everyone's in such pain and Trauma
that whoever they point you towards you
end up being like I'm I'm so angry okay
they're the enemy okay I need an enemy
right now and that's just you be on
guard for that kind of crap right so
it's like Chernobyl melts down and
they're picking that that radiation in
Switzerland yeah so that's a thousand
miles and so what you know if you even
if you nuke to Dubuque well what's
within a thousand miles of Dubuque and
you have you have so many cities Des
Moines Chicago like you have so many
cities that could also be affected by
the Dubuque it's all we're going to call
it it's all going to blow Easter
it's a very Russian way to say it they
like DB and all together you know yeah
so we have this other story Luke just
mentioned it the Russian nuclear
military train is seen on the move and
possible warning to the West that Putin
is prepared to escalate his Ukraine war
the military hardware belongs to 12th
main directorate of the Russian mod
specialist division is dedicated to
storage maintenance and and provision of
nukes here I was saying this earlier
everybody right now is talking about
nuclear weapons but yo these things are
like what 80 years old not like every
nuke is 80 years old but the technology
you have to imagine they've developed
different weapons by now right yeah
absolutely without a shadow of a doubt I
mean buying weapons 80 years 80 years
what we've seen in Nagasaki and
Hiroshima and those attacked major
cities that were key infrastructure for
of course the the Japanese military they
had a lot of factories there they had a
lot of production there what's what's uh
Russia going to do bomb China for
producing all the infrastructure for the
United States it does it so so there's a
lot of complexities to our modern day
and there's also talk of low-yield
nuclear weapons that don't have any
radioactivity that just provide kind of
a big boom there uh what we're talking
about right now is just crazy crazy
stuff that that is even Preposterous
that we're at this level where we're
where we are at right now this is crazy
I want to go back to World War II and
just imagine what they were thinking
before the deployment of nuclear your
bombs right they had rocket at the V2
Rockets they had you know what they had
Zeppelins dropping stuff or something
well they were using B2 or B-52s to drop
I think it'd be 52 drop Fire Bomb a
firebomb Dresden before the nukes went
off so that right there was already kind
of like a dramatic escalation imagine if
they in World War II were concerned
about the most powerful and devastating
weapon of like 1860. you know like we're
talking about 80 years ago we developed
these these fission bombs these nuclear
bombs and then of course since then
we've dramatically increased their power
by like 1 000 fold and put them on icbms
now we have this torpedo I'm willing to
bet I'm just gonna say it off top of my
head anti-matter weapons probably exist
in great yield you don't know what's
coming this is the this is the point of
modern Wars you don't know a big point
of it you watch the Great War on YouTube
fantastic Channel a documents World War
one week by week they didn't know what
machine guns were not really they didn't
know that they were running into a
machine gun for like weeks and weeks and
even maybe months they just got up and
just kept running and just kept getting
killed millions of people who just keep
running into this new weapon that they
didn't understand
and then in World War II they didn't
think a nuclear bomb was going to take
out Hiroshima they didn't know that that
existed that that potential was there
but
lo and behold one in a split second
things can change so this is a story
that broke last week last Friday the
first transgender uh officer in the US
Army right arrested being a Russian spy
traitor to our country now this is what
I found very very interesting in the
story what were the Russians after
so what what were presumably they
wanting what were they wanting what
information right that's right well they
weren't going after Delta Forces like
capacity of Firepower or what special
weapons they had or night vision goggles
they were going after the medical
records now what does this mean Gordon
Chang says that China is working on you
know biomedical
DNA
attracted you know devastating I'm not
sure how you would even call it like
what would you even call it DNA markers
that say like we're gonna make a
specific death for you based on your
genetic code and China's going full in
on this technology to figure out how to
kill full groups of people of course and
this of course is the James Bond so yeah
because you applied for the last James
Bond movie you don't want them to know
that you're attacking them that's the
point they want to do it invisibly
quietly subtly you don't want to drop
weapons that you see coming you guys
know about stuxnet
this was a cyber weapon developed by the
U.S and Israel to blow up Iranian
nuclear centrifuges to stop them from
obviously you know getting getting
nuclear power or weapons or whatever you
want to call it so this was a a cyber
weapon that was basically just spattered
across the planet they infected
everything and said sooner or later it
will find its way onto their computers
and it did
it did nothing until it found the
centrifuges and then it caused them to
spin until they exploded
but this virus was apparently on regular
machines and Industrial machines but it
wouldn't wouldn't do anything that's
exactly it I wonder if back then someone
saw that and said we can do that in the
computer can we do that in a person you
create a virus that will in buy a weapon
that will infect every person on the
planet but only cause damage in certain
DNA yeah was it what movie was it James
Bond James Bond this was the exact plot
of the last James Bond film and we know
that the Central Intelligence Agency has
a bureau in Hollywood that they openly
push the new Horrors to humanity through
Hollywood Cinema and that they are
probably concerned about this because
this is what was happening this exact
thing was happening James bondsville
there was a um there's a black character
female character right people thought
she might have been the new James Bond
right 007 takes time off and she becomes
double over seven anyway at the end of
the film The Mad Scientist is like I
could make a disease they're in their
his layer and he goes I could wipe out
your entire race right that was that was
his threat to her is that I could wipe
out your entire People based on the
genetic code hold on hold on right who
would this most negatively impact not
the United States
but it doesn't have to be about your
ethnic genetics it could be about a
trigger so like an external stimuli a
light or a sound could trigger your
genetic to do the thing it could be
um something you eat it could be a feel
and emotion you have could trigger it
that's some kind of chemical release in
your brain activates it or something
like that and then they did a mass
murder of a group at the beginning of
the movie and I mean obviously it's not
a documentary okay like it's James Bond
film but they killed a specific targeted
group of people because they all took a
tablet right they took a pill that you
could give the military let's say uh
everyone in the military they all take
like very similar medicines obviously
vaccine mandates so on and so forth and
so you could Target them based on the
medicine that they take there was some
show that I was watching what was it
Fringe oh yeah French had an episode
like this right where this guy is
developing this kind of smell that if
you smell it it kills you did you you
guys it was trying to Target a specific
person to go genetic something like that
something like that I don't know it's
been yeah I haven't seen it in a while
yo this is crazy because it feels like
we're all we all do these shows and
we're like nuclear weapons and then the
TVs like nuclear weapons and Putin and
everyone's like ah then meanwhile behind
the scenes and all the top secret you
know clearance stuff they're like if
only you knew dude bio weapons or no
joke well China was caught taking
people's coveted tests and then
genetically harvesting the DNA from it
U.S intelligence agencies were
specifically I was talking about this I
think a year ago on this show I was
saying hey the Chinese government is
stealing everyone's kovitz tests U.S
intelligence agencies are warning
medical facilities not to get uh rid of
their tests in a way where of course the
Chinese government could could get them
they have been getting them they have
been harvesting the data for multiple
reasons one is an economic reason
another reason could be of course a new
form of warfare germ warfare DNA
specific Warfare that I think is also on
the possibility but the more likely
possibility that of course people need
to understand here is that China also
wants to game the big Pharma market so
if they have everyone's DNA they know
what people would be getting sick of
they could start producing and
Manufacturing medicine to beat out big
Pharma and be become the next big
overruling kind of power so for all of
the people that may be listening and
they're going no that's crazy China's
not taking your DNA I Give You NPR China
wants your data and may already have it
February 24th 2021 from All Things
Considered they say exciting as covet
cases began to rise a year ago a Chinese
company contacted several U.S states and
offered to set up testing Labs as a
byproduct the Chinese firm Beijing
genomics Institute would likely gain
access to the DNA of those tested
the offer was tempting for State
struggling to set their own testing
facilities for a new virus and short
notice but U.S national security
officials urged the states to reject the
offer citing concerns about how China
might use personal data collected on
Americans we certainly reached out to
our partners in the community to make
sure blah blah blah blah this is just
one of the earlier stories yeah it
definitely makes you wonder why the
covet tests were free you know and
giving out to everyone no no hold on
though those who didn't return right so
what this is more about is facilities
where you'd pull up and they'd test you
and then we'll call you back later
exactly the covet test you got at home
you like snorted into or whatever and
then you threw it you had to buy those
right right right yeah but but free ones
they had your DNA sample no no the ones
they give you at your house they were
they were the same ones from the grocery
store or whatever yeah this is what
they're talking about is they were there
were places you could go to get tested
where you'd drive up in your car they'd
stick you in the nose and say we'll call
you back on Wednesday and let you know
that's where the concern is on whether
or not they were getting access to your
DNA I mean to Luke's Point how much of
our Pharmaceuticals is processed in
China a lot majority I mean the vast
majority I don't know the exact number
I'm sure it's easily fine you know you
usually find it and Google it right now
yeah vitamin C supplements all of it
antibiotics I just want to make sure
American Pharmaceuticals they go into
China I want to make sure I clarify too
as much as they go on to say that um you
know these states turn it down this is
funny they're like the national
Securities that don't do it because you
know China would get access to your data
we certainly reach out to our partners
in the community to make sure oh it
sounds like it didn't happen NPR goes on
to say Beijing genomics Institute a
major Global player in the worlds of
genomics research report a set of labs
and at least 18 other countries and
provided covet testing kits to 180
Nations including the US great U.S
officials stress their main concern was
preventing the establishment of
full-service Labs the officials do not
consider the testing kits to pose a
serious risk biotech companies in China
the US and elsewhere routinely collect
DNA and use it blah blah blah you get it
you get it so here's the other crazy
thing too is like ancestry and like was
it 2023 me I'm just looking it up people
are just like I'm gonna give my DNA and
then a company buys 23andMe who owns it
I don't know do you know the guy that
owns 23 and me personally I believe also
the FDA made an announcement that they
were taking some of the tests and
running uh uh larger uh projects and
scientific experiments with them based
off human DNA okay now I know it sounds
freaky right but hear me out what if the
genomics lab that is everybody's DNA
releases a virus and it turns people
into crazy like animal hybrids like
werewolves and lizard people wouldn't
that be cool uh um reality is a lot
scarier than your fiction here Tim
especially when you look at individuals
Animorphs animals
what animal well I'm not what animal
would you become if you were an animal
well I'm not saying that people get the
ability to choose a term saying like
they would be forcefully turned into a
variety of different animals like Lou
could be like a lemur guy and you know
it would be a horse dude or something
and can we start talking about the
billionaires that are invested in a lot
of these companies individuals like Bill
Gates that are literally creating GMO
genetically engineered mosquitoes that
are meant to wipe out the populations of
mosquitoes and if you could do this too
one group of animals what makes you
think he can't do it to another group
can we can we can we talk about Bill
Gates real quick because uh before this
yeah of course of course we have this we
have this story
from slay news Bill Gates warned civil
war is coming we'll bring it all to an
end but we've covered this before we
covered the story and actually got a ton
of play but Luke mentioned something
else that Bill Gates has a group of
people tracking what people say about
him on the internet and I didn't believe
it and so Luke was like pull it up
there's a quote from from Bill Gates
quote I have a group that tracks what's
on the web that's talking about things
that connect to me he said
overwhelmingly during the pandemic 95
was all the conspiracy theories that
were right they were right hold on
majority of it I would say 95 of that
stuff nothing yeah majority of it a lot
of it there were some crazy uh Looney
Tunes that talked about aliens and all
this other stuff to muddy the waters
here there was a lot of crazy people
that made stuff stuff up out of nowhere
but when it came to the scientists the
professionals the researchers uh the
politicians who came forward that were
censored they were deemed conspiracy
theories and a lot of them were right
and they weren't talking about Bill
Gates
a lot of the stuff people talk about
Bill Gates they go over the top with you
need to talk about Bill Gates in the
comments no no he says not about him he
says the pandemic he says overwhelming
during the pandemic it was all
conspiracy stuff right talking about
talking about him he says connect to me
he was saying that people were talking
about him and and during the pandemic it
was all conspiracy theory stuff
I'm saying be careful about the weird
lizard people attempts because I said
they discredit you absolutely focus on
Bill Gates's Ted Talk where he says we
need to reduce population growth well
and then they start doing these things
claiming it's not about population
growth and I have to wonder what their
priorities are yeah but not only that if
you look at the statement above what the
quote that you just read there it says
specifically Gates also revealed that
he's been trying to come up with the
solution for tracking tackling
misinformation and conspiracy theories
so he's he's going after the individuals
who pretty much overall a lot of them
have been batting a hundred he's the one
he's the main guy funding News Guard
he's the one funding a lot of these
factors real quick we get a lot of flack
for this Microsoft has a as a contract
with the News Guard not direct funding
of course he's but but he also came out
and it recently was revealed that he
funded Dan Crenshaw Mitt Romney Marco
Rubio he's also of course behind the
inflation reduction act he's bragging
about how he made that bill was a part
of writing it he's going to be enforcing
it this is the bill that of course
provides 80 000 new IRS agents is going
to be centralizing a lot of control and
regulations here so I mean this man with
242
000 acres in 18 states talking about
keeping an eye on people who talk about
him I mean that that should that should
raise some eyebrows we also have this
story Bill Gates admits that telling
people not to eat meat won't solve
climate change despite previously saying
U.S should move to 100 synthetic beef
and investing in plant-based firms you
know look they do all these things they
say climate change but it kind of feels
like what they're really saying is
overpopulation
well yeah and and also this is
self-interested Bill Gates has a lot of
patents a lot of Investments and a lot
of money into meatless diets that of
course a lot of the science has been
questioned some of the science has
actually even been debunked and and
purely does highlight something that a
lot of people do see as something
nefarious since of course meat
especially organ meat has a lot of
important macronutrients has a lot of
important uh nutrition that a lot of
people are being denied the access to so
a lot of people are of course are coming
up with theories but obviously with this
man having so much control so much land
so much money so much power there should
at least be some accountability at least
some criticism to him and his his
organization I think the factory farming
industry is grotesque and it's not
something that gets enough attention in
modern media like when you see the pools
of large lakes of blood and feces like
brown red these mud that they and
they'll ban like drones above their
factories so you can't see them and then
when you see in like internal videos of
like these no offense to people able to
work in these jobs because I don't know
what the hell that must be like to kill
animals all day but like like people
that have gone so far they see the pig
and they just think it's it's it's a
thing that I need to kill right now and
they'll take baby ones and smash them
pick them up by their leg and smash
their heads on the concrete you hear the
baby pigs squealing and dying and then
it's like this is how we have been
sourcing the meat for this amount of
population I get where Bill Gates is
coming from because this is grotesque
I think it's part of what about all the
animals and he's that's not what he's
saying but what about all the other
animals that are killed and hurt in the
making of a lot of these you know vegan
oh yeah when you talk about when they
Harvest Grain for instance they take
these combines and they grind up huge
amounts of wheat but all these deer are
in there they just hunker down and wait
rabbits I mean it's the not animal
friendly the way that they harvest
absolutely Mass amounts of grain
absolutely not but but again this is not
kind of what what Bill Gates is yeah
he's not talking about that he's talking
about it takes too much carbon to make a
cow and factory farming is intensely
carbon it's carbon intensive the crazy
thing I learned lot of burps the crazy
thing I learned is that Broiler chickens
Factory right like you know people say
like such thing as a factory farm look
at these pictures of like this building
full of just chickens six weeks until
they they harvest the chicken that's
crazy to me because we have you know
backyard chickens six weeks is Tiny you
know so it's got them on steroids they I
guess yeah they're hopped up on goof
balls to make them grow real quick and
nasty like yeah but I don't know look
just because we have problems in that
capacity I'll I'll admit Bill Gates
telling people not to eat meat is is
nuts my point here is they keep saying
climate change but look at the actions
that they're engaged in when they're
saying hey we want to get rid of fossil
fuels it's like okay well people will
die if you do that it's like yeah well
climate change it's like okay well we
don't want people farming in the
Netherlands right now during a food
shortage you know during a war it's like
okay well that's not climate change
they're like we're concerned about
nitrogen levels in the Netherlands it's
like yeah but there's a food shortage
coming because of the war in Ukraine
right like oh yeah well whatever they
should stop making food so you want the
food to be worse that there was a great
point that was brought up by Jeremy
boring when he's on the show and he said
nothing matters about humans we are
humans our experience is human we care
about The Human Experience so this idea
that we would sacrifice Humanity for
something else makes no sense okay he
said something to that effect I don't
want to misquote him but he made a
really good point
like humans exist for humans right like
we we we we have to be good stewards of
the earth that's what he said but also
like our drives our passions our desires
our experiences is relative to to humans
so if we were thinking of sacrificing
all of humanity for the sake of you know
climate change well what's the point
stopping climate change to save humans
when humans are going to die if you
don't have food something doesn't add up
there you know what I mean yeah I think
that there's you know the person saying
there's too many people in this world so
you got to give us all the power and all
the money because we are going to help
everyone uh should really have someone
looking a side-eyed at them and again
you have to look at Bill Gates and the
work that he's produced you know the the
products that he produced Vanda Vandana
Shiva actually came out and and did a
very excellent uh kind of speech about
what Bill Gates has done to India with
his centralization of farmers you see
what he has called for you see the work
that he has done with China advising
them working with them on many projects
calling for many of the most restrictive
coveted policies celebrating their
lockdowns I mean this this is a man who
has a vision for Humanity that I think
should be critiqued a little bit and not
promoted because the corporate media
regurgitates a lot of what he has to say
uncritically as of course he also gives
hundreds of millions of dollars to the
corporate media he's invested in the
guardian the BBC MSNBC and his money has
been spread around everywhere especially
in the scientific Community where it has
created the bill chill where many
scientists are even too afraid to
criticize him or his products because
they know some kind of funding is going
to be taken away if they criticize him
and this is why in my opinion Bill Gates
is bragging about how he has people that
track people online that talk about him
as he's now trying to delve into dealing
with misinformation and conspiracy
theories yeah it's not a coincidence
why can't these Super Rich ass people
just like be super rich and be happy
what is the emptiness in their soul what
is driving this now as a Christian I can
like I I have my own thoughts on this
however like why why make the world the
worst place well why take away meat for
the rest of us like what a miserable
existence take away your abilities
guy works a nine to five in the cold
pits and all he wants is to put a
hamburger you got on the grill you got
it backwards where is the opposition
why is it that Bill Gates and all of
these other billionaires are dumping
money into wokeness CRT climate change
stuff and then on the inverse nothing I
mean literally not literally nothing but
dramatically less yeah you know I talk
about this quite a bit and I I was
saying once you know I wish people who
had money would do things with it and
they don't and some people point out
yeah but like the woke people do and
then I was like yeah that's a good point
maybe people shouldn't and then I
thought about you know Mackenzie Bezos
got what 28 billion dollars for
divorcing Jeff and then she puts two
billion dollars into work stuff at least
it was reported from some Outlets she's
dumping all this money into all these
whoa causes and then I'm just like okay
where's the story about a major
libertarian conservative anti-welcome
person doing something similar I went to
Morgantown West Virginia it's like a
college town and it's rundown and
there's a lot of reasons why it is and
it seems like it's orchestrated big
investment firms drive up the price of
of building so that no one in the
community can buy them so that
businesses can't be open nobody can
afford rent and then it becomes this
just slum then they start giving out
free needles to everybody and now
everything is just crime poverty drugs
and then I'm like
one billionaire a billionaire could go
in there and buy like seven buildings
and then just be like make stuff to the
community to revitalize everything they
can counter it why don't they do stuff
like that why is that it's always people
like Bill Gates and George Soros now I
know long ago there were stories of the
Coke brothers or whatever I don't know
what they what they were doing or they
are doing I just know that as much as
there is some stuff that Peter Thiel
does for the most part we only ever hear
about these big woke leftist
billionaires who think there's too many
people when we get close Elon Musk gets
close to buying Twitter and doing
something he then says I'm gonna back I
was a bad idea I don't want to do it
yeah this is why we can't have nice
things to you to your point about this
and I know I'm not sure this is germane
to the conversation but Dave Chappelle
to his great credit deserves
um I think a lot of a plum for just
going to some middle of nowhere town in
Ohio and then going to the Town Council
meetings to keep like corporations for
moving in and like arguing on behalf of
little pubs and little breweries and
like little restaurants that are there
Dave Chappelle if you haven't looked
into this like has a little to your
point like has he's a I don't know how
much money he has definitely a multi
multi-millionaire Dave Chappelle goes
into this little town uh in the middle
of truly nowhere in Ohio and he just
like saves the city like saves the like
nice genteel like nature of the city and
he actually went and argued against a
huge development that was going to come
into the town because it's been
popularized probably because of Dave
Chappelle and he killed it he got it he
killed it and then he bought the land so
no one could develop yep which is very
neat which is actually uh similar to
what you just described but it it is
it's it's good we're we're doing a big
play with Times Square on New Year's
we're getting the whole North Tower
we're getting a percentage of it so
every 90 seconds we're gonna have 10 to
15 seconds of the whole North Tower
except for there's two ads owned by like
Coke and Eminem or something but I was
like we should do things that assert
ourselves in these cultural spaces yes
and make people aware that like we are
winning we're growing we're taking over
so that was like something big we did
this year we're planning you know we're
trying to come up with it with an idea
for a bunch of culture jamming marketing
stuff next year and I think about that
I'm just like you know when I go to
these small towns and peop I met this
local guy and he was like you should
consider buying here to help bring
things back and and you know kind of
kick things up a notch
there are a bunch of buildings with the
pride flags all over the place and we
both agree we were talking about it that
people are just doing that because
they're scared they're scared of the
violent terrorists and so long as there
is no counter it's just going to keep
spreading people are going to put up
Flags not because they believe in it
because they're like this stops people
from beat from attacking my business yo
if I had a billion dollars I'd go in
there and be like okay I'll buy these
three that building that building in
that building and then we'll get some
locals in the community who oppose this
stuff just to to create the space they
want to create invest in that invest in
the future of this country I think the
problem is and there was this guy Nate
shout out Nate it's nice meeting you he
said we had a protest out here and BLM
and these other groups are showing up
and none of these like most of the town
it's West Virginia they oppose the stuff
and none of them could take any time out
of their day to come out and say no to
these people and then I was like that's
it right there isn't it they they won't
even show up to say no that's a bummer
so the Passover is when the spirit of
death the right passes over the
households of Egypt and it doesn't kill
the firstborn son as long as you put
Lamb's blood right on your door this is
what Passover is very high holiday High
Jewish holiday uh still celebrated
Christian or Jewish uh traditions
and so in Washington DC I've literally
watched people do a a metaphorical like
hedonistic Passover on their home so I
lived on Capitol Hill in a very bad
neighborhood where you like a couple
blocks from Jack besobic uh had antifa
come after Jack that famous photo of
Jack like staring down antifa where they
were looking to tear down our Lincoln
Statue there's a statue of Abraham
Lincoln they wanted to tear it down
there were mobs putting you know nooses
around it to rip it down people put up
gay rights flags and BLM Flags in their
yards literally as like a please don't
come here thing I know these people
we're not uh some of them were
Republicans and they were not on board
with this they needed to wave these
flags and put the stuff up in order to
like stop the mobs from coming to their
street you remember Rand Paul almost got
beat like to death with his wife Kelly
Paul outside of the White House after
Donald Trump's speech at the 2020 RNC
convention I got like seven feet from
that watching that happen I mean it's
like it it really is uh terroristic
almost it's domestic terrorism and then
you go back to DC this is my first time
back in a year because I moved away a
year ago I was like I followed I
followed this great podcast faster I
listen to every single day his advice is
he goes get out of the Cities get out of
the Cities Jack masobic must have been
Jack great beard fantastic hat and I
followed that advice we went you know
sort of down to I guess I guess Tampa is
a larger City but it's not like DC I
mean very different from DC in so many
ways I was just back in DC for the first
time in a year man I like the Decay
there's no better word for it there's
just there's there's entropy that is
happening to that City I lived there for
15 years I worked on Capitol Hill I've
asked questions in White House briefings
I've been all over that City and and
I've never seen anything like it first
off there's tent cities
uh as soon as you get into the nation's
capital which you shouldn't have in a
nation's capital right so if you're if
you're visiting from another country you
shouldn't see like squalor intent cities
and then there's no one there and the
people who are there it's like a Zombie
Town the people who are there masked
like triple masked like walking around
here's a photo from a store I had to run
into a store and grab an item here's a
photo that says um
at uh Nordstrom this is at a Nordstrom
uh rack that said the gas pipeline right
Nordstrom too Hispanic and latinx his
sporadic and latinx welcome here
were they banned before
why'd you ban the Latino people from
your from your store that's not okay
these don't understand like how to issue
a notice to let people know they weren't
doing it anymore yeah like that's that's
what I got from that the decay in the
entropy is really happening in real time
it was shocking for me to go back oh
yeah so you know I we're looking at
setting up a brick and mortar location
probably gonna be we've been talking
about doing like a community center kind
of thing and I've got these people for
one the real estate markets these the
whole Market itself everything's just
insane and they're trying to get insane
away or bad way it's just insane insane
like they're they're they're they're
they're trying to sell property for
substantially more than you could even
make money off of it's it's just that
you they want to sell a building it's
half a million dollars and you're like
you're in an area with no foot traffic
no customers how is this money worth
anywhere near that you know even if you
if you opened a a chicken restaurant you
would be able to sell enough to cover
the cost of the mortgage in this area is
insane and they're like it's worth it
and I think a lot of it has to do with
these big investment firms they keep
buying up property which keeps the
prices artificially High nobody wants to
sell because they're convinced it'll be
worth it then the cities start decaying
so I go to these places we had one story
where trying to buy this building and
they're telling me how great at the city
is how good it's going to be and I'm
like the local Diner is closed on a
Saturday at noon because nobody wants to
have it nobody can nobody's working so
if I can't even go to a store and every
business is closed no one is here what
makes you think there's value in this
location they're like it's worth it and
it's to me it's just
it's that kind of mentality that's
stopping people from investing in their
towns from actually building community
and then everyone just sits at home on
the internet and does nothing or they
were raptured I don't know that's the
other joke where is everybody like you
mentioned like in DC like where is
everybody in Florida in DC in DC it's
estimated that 70 000 people moved out
of DC in 2021 and it's estimated in 2021
that 220 000 people moved to Florida so
these are just like rough estimates but
uh again A lot of people are moving
where the freedom usually is more
available where there's less taxes less
government less regulations and a lot of
times that's Florida do you guys see
that video of those two dudes the gas
tanker comes in
and the guy's like you can talk all that
ish about DeSantis but he brought the
gas to Arcadia I know
I'm a Democrat yeah
[Laughter]
shout out to Rhonda Santos for handling
the the potential looting in Florida
after the hurricane because I mean he
came out immediately he was like don't
even think about it yeah you go to a
house you don't know what they got
behind that door good luck trying to
take someone's stuff well they're
insinuating you're gonna get shot
they're armed don't mess with people's
property there was a lot of signs from
the citizens there just you know
themselves saying you loot we shoot good
so that's the culture that that comes
from Florida of individuals saying hey
this is my property hey a lot of us get
to have the right to defend ourselves
and you should think twice before trying
to hurt or steal from another innocent
human this breakdown of Law and Order is
completely insane it's antithetical to
the the culture of the United States
that we would let rioters and looters
destroy the country and then the Flames
grow greater in 21 and you're like dude
I'm not like I don't want Chinese
authoritarian communism I don't want
that but I want to see the National
Guard on the street when people are
trying to firebomb a building I want
them stopped yo okay yo this is wild all
right wild and I have this out because
the first thing I got when I got to
Florida concealed carry permit right
this is the first thing you don't need
that in West Virginia you can never get
you don't need that in New Hampshire but
I got one too blown out this is the
SE uh this is this isn't okay see Ian to
your point
so I made my Uber stop uh short of my
hotel and I got out to like look at the
burned down edifice of the White House
now you would say a Betty nobody burned
down the White House well the White
House is a giant ground right and
there's grounds Keepers facilities on
the White House grounds that are
considered part of the White House and
those ground Keepers facilities were
torched down this was the burning
building when the antifa mobs attacked
it was in July attacked the White House
right and they injured some 90 Secret
Service agents and so on and so forth
firebomb the guard posts barricades down
to fight of the church set them up 529
Insurrection May 29th yeah we talked
about this so sorry like have you guys
seen what it looks like so it's still
burnt they haven't fixed it at all it's
still burned it's melted to it's very
it's on the other camera because I
actually filmed it to put up on our to
put up on our Channel shout out to the
Benny Johnson channel it's linked in the
YouTube please go follow us
um this is insanity they haven't touched
it it's like like a memorial to the
leftist Insurrection it's still there I
encourage everybody if you're in
Washington DC to go to the White House
grounds and to just look at these still
burned down the Flint you can still see
the blackened flames of the building
they haven't touched it it's been two
years they haven't they haven't improved
it they haven't tried to fix it it's
just sitting there burned down right by
Andrew Jackson they're right by the
famous shot of the White House right you
see it on the state of the union and
everything and it's this burned down
edifice like a memorial to what the left
did it's almost like they're proud of
what they were able to do when Donald
Trump was in office when they were able
to Stage their own Insurrection I I
don't know if it's like one of two paths
either we we bring in the military to
stop the the Riders this Philadelphia I
keep seeing all the street violence and
Philly shops getting destroyed if we
bring in the military and then we become
some authoritarian regime or if we just
let the mobs take over and then we have
a new a new mafia running the country
and it's basically young disaffected men
that are gang banging or whatever dudes
Jitters we already have them Mafia yeah
it's called government well I'm talking
about local like 17 year olds that have
illegal like handguns that are like
legal handguns yeah illegal hand like a
a concealed Pistols that they don't have
licenses for or whatever and I don't
want I don't want the mafia running the
show but that's what it feels like when
I look at videos and I'm obviously I'm
being manipulated by social media but
that's what it feels like but this is
why I say get out of cities it was it
was the reason I said Jack was because
he was saying that before I was saying
it you know he was warning people for a
while to get out of cities but I was
like yeah you know sorry Jack well no no
I mean we say it a lot on the show too
because we did leave we were on the
other side of the river from
Philadelphia in Jersey and then I left
New York I went there and I said this
isn't fixing anything so we came out to
the middle and sort of middle of nowhere
we're still close enough to DC but
that's that's the idea if these 17 year
old kids with their
um constitutionally protected Firearms
yes end up acting a fool and taking over
cities you ain't gonna be there and I'll
tell you this if you were out in Maga
country in West Virginia and something
bad happened it is going to be
substantially better because you're not
going to have roving bands of teenagers
you're gonna have like farmers and their
families and their neighbors coming
together and it's going to be not
perfect probably pretty bad in certain
ways but way way more organized like I
think that as the liberal economic order
crumbles in like the US Dollars no
longer the world reserved people are
falling into poverty living on the
street that is it inevitable that these
cities just turn into Battlegrounds that
it's either going to be the military
mowing people down that are trying to
destroy property or it's going to be
gangs mowing people down because they
want the property like is it one or the
other can we find a peaceful solution in
the cities what do you think
so there was looting in Tampa there was
one incident during the hurricane of of
looters going through going through
Tampa my neighborhood and uh they were
caught immediately they were arrested
immediately uh by the police and then
you could go every single house
every other house and find a homie on
his uh doorstep with firearm
like dad's just got their guns as I sat
outside
and there was not a single looting
incident for the entire like three extra
days of the hurricane because it like
rain it was rainy and windy like what
you mean the police didn't come and save
everybody and protect the neighborhoods
it was the locals who were just the
locals who sat there on their porches
including what I limited to you're
Shirley who's very happy to have a gun
safe now finally and I can build up my
little uh Arsenal here but my neighbor I
come up the street I was at Home Depot
got some um uh uh potting soil right so
this is better than a sandbag so don't
take hurricane advice from a guy who's
just been in Florida for one year but
you can put bags of potting soil up and
they act as a sandbag and they're a lot
more they're like more available and
then you can use them afterwards because
I don't know if you're gonna make like a
Sandbox or something you can actually
pot your plants right it's going to be
really pretty weather beautiful weather
after the hurricane
so I'm driving back from Home Depot and
I look over here to Johnny
is my neighbor John he's 50 years old
Johnny rides a Harley and here's Johnny
he's an engineer and he's sitting there
with his double barrel like off like on
his lap you know I was like Johnny did
somebody like uh send your daughter a
naughty DM or what like what happened
right what's the double barrel about
he's like yo there's looters in the
neighborhood no we're just uh making
sure they know not in my neighborhood
and then up and down the street you see
like people
sitting there with their firearms and Yo
No More looting that's the third choice
then it's you don't want the to rely on
the government because they're just
going to become a autocrats you don't
want to let the gangs destroy you got to
have the civilians armed and protecting
their individual property so maybe it's
time in these cities to lighten up on
gun restrictions encourage people to
start training you allow law abiding
innocent human beings to be able to
defend themselves just like the
criminals who have all the firearms and
I think I know what video you're talking
about uh it was from Chicago allegedly
of of children from from junior high
school and they all had Glocks with
switches on it that made them automatic
pistols uh and uh constitutionally
protected but not legal in Chicago yes
it's Chicago of course being a place
where they of course have the strictest
gun control laws but you know teenagers
14 year olds are running around with
automatic Glocks and of course the
average citizen can't even have a pocket
knife to defend themselves because
they'll go to jail if the cops find it
on them yeah that's crazy
that of course is not fair for the
average human being that it's not fair
for someone that is is not trying to
hurt anyone or or an individual who just
wants to defend themselves that can't
and allows criminals to run free with
with yeah because they'll take the guns
anyway the criminals they don't care
about the law I think what's going to
happen it's going to build up and
violence we're going to see this street
violence we'll probably see more of it
as people become more poor more people
in the street and then a city is going
to be like guns are legal now
constitutional carry everyone can carry
and that cities the crime is going to
plummet in that City that's right you
know how hard it would be to get one of
these in DC I tried for years years in
Washington DC to get one of these
there's one licensed firearm dealer
there's one licensed instructor they can
train one person at a time
so DC versus Heller happens right in
2009 2008 2008 DC versus hausler Heller
DC used to be for like 30 years you
couldn't own any Firearms at all decent
for seller overturns this and so what
they did is the bureaucracy comes in and
just makes firearm even though the
Supreme Court said no you will allow the
sale of firearms the bureaucracy comes
in and says okay we'll limit it to a
store and a guy and that person and then
and then multiple police officers that
you need to speak with right so I tried
the process I was drowning paperwork I
was just choked out by the bureaucracy I
could not get my concealed carry in DC I
tried for years it was too difficult it
was too difficult meanwhile on my block
on 19th Street Capitol Hill you could
call it like a gentrifying well I live
right next to a drug dealer right next
to a crack dealer
um that guy had so many guns they were
they were doing open air gun sales
on my street the week that I left the
week I decided to move there was an open
air gun sale going on on the street the
guy who opened up his truck and he had I
don't know what he had like a a ton of
firearms sitting there you know you made
the right price you just pick it up out
of his trunk right there was a shooting
there was deadly shooting on my street
that the police had to come get my
footage from this was two weeks before
we left right guy gets shot in my yard
jumps into the rose bush
um you know we played on the show a
couple times but what what do you need a
concealed permit for when you can just
hire a an armed security guard who does
all the work for you and and you could
have armed security guards all around
you as you walk around you mean like AOC
like all like all the politicians yeah
and and the wealthy individuals who eat
at these Steakhouse and the lobbyists
who don't need to apply for a permit
because they just pay for several men
who get the permits and then
surround them they also got walls that's
this is what they do they the reason why
the these Elites are okay with banning
guns is because guns are only banned for
poor people now it would be hard for
them to get a firearm as well even
though they are wealthy but you pay
someone a couple hundred grand per year
they take the time and energy to go get
the permit and get the guns and they
surround you and you don't have to think
twice about it don't worry you're pretty
little wealthy hat off that's why they
vote for this stuff so that poor people
can't have weapons but they can yeah and
they call for machine gun turrets at the
the capital as of course they tell you
that you can't have a firearm it's
absolutely that's crazy you see the
video of her saying they're shipping the
migrants north but the farmers say we
didn't pick our crops yeah the Florida
Farmers wow Florida
Florida farmers are very she talks like
this they're saying to me why are you
sending the migrants left we need them
to pick our crops and it's just like
they're here illegally they're not
legally allowed to work and you're
telling me that farmers are advocating
for the commission of a crime to you and
you agree with them uh yo you do know
that Martha uh that that Nancy Pelosi
owns a Vineyard right where yeah she has
a Vineyard this is where Paul Pelosi was
driving to drunk off his ass like uh two
o'clock in the morning three o'clock in
the morning he was going back to their
Vineyard so of course this is this is
this hits home for Nancy okay sure
where's the lady from yeah right that's
right I picked the grapes and you
wouldn't want the Chardonnay grapes that
are they kicked raw they're not getting
picked with the beautiful hands okay
that handle the grapes correctly they're
getting picked like a week too late that
makes bad Chardonnay and ain't nobody
dislike her bad Chardonnay I didn't know
that does that make bad Chardonnay I
have no idea oh cause you had me worried
I was actually sympathetic to Nancy I
was like oh we don't want a shark
in St Helena California makes her the
fourth richest uh Californian in
Congress as of 2015. I'd like to see how
that's evolved
yeah uh okay that's interesting
soft hands picking the Chardonnay grapes
I think she's very detached from
uh from Law and Order if she thinks that
we should just deal with it I don't
understand what I don't understand this
why they're trying to stop people from
governing themselves it's really that
really bothers me
I'm gonna I'm gonna can we play the I I
had to pull up the video oh yeah we
gotta watch this we've got to play it we
have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these uh
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the cops down here
I just love that she's like wait a
second we need them to pick the crops is
like the permanent perennial Democrat
talking point it goes all the way back
to the founding of the Democrat Party we
need them to pick the crops it's always
been the issue for Democrats that's true
it's just changed it's just remarkable
to me that she's basically saying right
now to the press and everyone else a
group of farmers said we are employing
people illegally who enter the country
illegally please don't take these people
away from us and there's just so much
here where it's like well Nancy is an
officer of the of the government maybe
you could inform law enforcement that
crimes are being committed and they're
requesting of you to assist them in the
crimes being committed and your only
response to be like they like it that
that's just the the people who are
coming and you earlier in the show you
said criminal and criminal migrant
Criminal Minds because we took our laws
right and that's that's like you know I
hear a lot from the left they're like no
one's illegal and I'm like that's a good
point a person isn't illegal but they
can't be criminals and if you break the
law and you're here you're a criminal
migrant that makes sense so she's
actually here arguing for the law to be
broken
it's
I don't know chaos what was the word we
were talking about um when the cities
are Decay Decay degradation it doesn't
mean you're a bad person I live in a
completely cubanate like there's a Cuban
neighborhood right Tampa is the number
one buy City by city population the
number one Landing place for Cuban
migrants and I like I assume most of
them were not here legally right they
came from Cuba there was a lot of them
and they they came illegally those
people are the best patriots man those
people are awesome Tampa is an amazing
Community if you ever go to Ybor City in
Tampa get a hand-rolled cigar get a
proper Cuban coffee it looks like it
looks like Havana should should look
without without the communism I don't I
don't think people should be illegal
entering the country but I will say I
have infinitely more respect for illegal
immigrants fleeing communism and even
the the migrant from Honduras was like I
want Buffalo Wild Wings Coming to
America I have more respect for them
than the leftists who are like America
is evil and racist yes now I'm not happy
that they break the law to come here
because they want Buffalo Wild Wings as
for the people fleeing communism fleeing
here and then applying for Asylum I get
and hopefully they get it because
communism sucks but you have too many
people in this country who just outright
hate it despite the fact that everyone's
fleeing to get here
I mean I call them criminal migrants for
that exact reason I'm not trying to say
that that anyone should break our laws
to come here you weren't invited and and
by the way this is this is Democrat law
this was passed and ratified by Joe
Biden of all people in the in the Senate
uh where if you are if you cross our
border illegally it is your uh dude it
is your duty to turn yourself in
immediately to border patrol and and and
then to essentially like surrender
yourself right to authorities that that
is the law of the land so it is a legal
act it is a felony it is a federal
felony to cross our border illegally and
that is the that is the black law of the
land so so the Joe Biden is breaking the
law this is a law of course that he
ratified because you you re-up this and
then you you re-ratify this is the
Immigration Act Immigration Act of like
1964 or 1963 I can't remember but anyway
I again I just it's it's it's a criminal
act that's why we call him a criminal
you're a criminal migrant 1965.
immigration and nationality Act of 1965.
Yep this it's reminiscent of the slave
trade the African slave trade people are
coming over though then it was legal
what they were doing highly amoral You
could argue but they were shipping
humans over in Chains and then putting
them on the plantation to work for low
wages these people are coming across
illegally whether they're being
trafficked across like the slaves were
of the African slave trade or if they're
coming over their own will and then
they're working for cheap labor like
it's very similar are they gonna then I
don't want to be cynical about it man
but I'm like in 200 years or their
ancestors going to be asking for
reparations because they were poor they
came from poverty like it it
I don't know man but there it's not
they're not in Bound and chains that's
the difference is they're here because
it's better than where they were which
is a lot of them were also working
illegally a lot of them are being taken
advantage of a lot of multinational
corporations use them and depend on them
to get rich while of course not
following the regulations not following
the rules not even paying them minimum
wage in many instances so who's the real
winner here a lot of the Big Top
multinational corporations as of course
wages go down because there's an influx
of workers housing goes up as of course
there's less housing and who loses the
Blue Collar the average American the
person who is here who came here without
the right paperwork who of course is
going to be a slave of the multinational
corporations taking advantage I think
this uh the statement from Pelosi should
be probable cause probable cause enough
to check the check the documentation of
her Plantation yes or absolutely
Plantation Pelosi that's why we call our
Plantation and also if the people that
want like reparations or are upset about
the African-American slave trade in the
history and everything that's going on
right now with racism you got to to turn
your focus on the illegal immigration
racket in the United States because
those are the modern day slaves if you
want to fix the past to start with the
present there's still slavery right now
in in Libya because of the U.S overthrow
of that government there which Hillary
Clinton orchestrated celebrated and now
Africans who are trying to go to the
Middle East are literally being put as
and sold as slaves inside of Libya right
now as we're speaking so like are you
still a slave if your chains are
invisible no there's real chains in
Libya okay it's Libya There's real
chains I would argue that a lot of the
people that are coming across the border
based on our border visit down to Yuma
Arizona and we went and spent two days
in Yuma Arizona in the Yuma sector and
we talked with the sheriff there and he
droves around he got we got in our
little truck we drove along the border
we drove along Trump's wall it was
glorious and then it just ends right it
just ends part of it is because it ends
because of an Indian reservation and
they're working with the tribe to get it
built on there part of it ends because
Joe Biden just letting the wall rust in
the middle of the desert the uh uh the
sheriff drives us uh to the middle of uh
where they cross and he says that's the
the rape tree
go over to the rape tree that's how the
women pay their toll because they don't
have any money to get in America
so in case you're wondering how this
works go over there and we go over there
there's like there's like ripped
clothing there's like panties there's
like all this horrible stuff there's
little children's toys I like like every
little stuffed animals it's sickening it
is a lot of it is and it is the largest
human slave trade I would argue because
these people that are coming here as
indentured to Luke's Point indentured
like servants right to work for
corporations and again they get shipped
off to uh Iowa hog Factory right they
already have like their papers right
that's where they go they work for the
coyotes yo it is the world's largest
human smuggling operation or slave trade
depending on if you think the caves are
invisible the coyotes tell some of these
people not every single one works this
way they'll say it's you know two or
three thousand dollars to get uh to get
your passage paid for and if you don't
have it you'll work to pay us pay it off
so these people are coming in they're
coming they're coming indebted to these
human traffickers then they have to work
and send money back I remember I once
went to a restaurant and uh I'll keep
the the the uh the details more vague
but people who worked there were all
clearly migrants and someone got really
mad the tip wasn't big enough and it was
because we didn't have a server we come
into a restaurant with no server we
order up at the counter we sit down and
then afterwards they demanded a tip and
I'm like if we had a waiter like I
usually tip really well they started
yelling at us and so what what I was
told from someone is that the people who
come here they're indentured servants
they get paid quote unquote but they
have this extra legal system where back
home there's there's rules and laws that
apply to them here in America that don't
apply in America but it's like we paid
five grand to move it to America you're
gonna work for our company that our
people own we're gonna pay you and then
you're gonna send the money back to us
or else so if they they need to make a
certain amount of money every week to
send it back home to pay off the debt to
get them to move to America so they get
really mad when you're not giving them
more money than they do the or else part
makes them slaves for sure like if they
are afraid made for their families lives
or afraid they're going to get hunted
down if they don't if they don't work
then they're in a state of slavery yeah
isn't the number one source of income in
Mexico remittances from the United
States did I read that somewhere wow is
that true I believe that how does that
how does that work uh so it's money
coming from the United States for people
who are sending it back to Mexico so
that's the number one source of income
or a very high level source of income I
would like to have an article to check
that but we've we've read it on the show
before
there's heavy wire transfers and stuff
that do they track it how's that there's
a lot of seven dollar bills cash too
yeah I love that Western Union Bitcoin
all of it I love how these like Urban
Millennial liberal types have started
colonizing Mexico City
that's true I mean you saw the story
they're like all moving down there and
they're like I just love these tacos the
rent is so cheap locals are just like
this is terrible you don't speak our
language and you're ruining our favorite
spots yeah that story was something else
yeah a plague dude a lot of American
cities
the woke the woke liberals yeah yeah I
mean like try to go try to go have like
a nice time in LA or in Detroit or into
Chicago you're from Chicago yeah and
right like talk about another ghost town
like Michigan Avenue I mean I haven't
been there stores are closed down in
Michigan oh man it's like well I mean
there's only so many cars you can drive
into the storefronts right during the
riots and then have like 150 people run
in that video where the guys are
shooting at the window to try and break
into like a Dolce store or whatever it
was called I mean it's it's Decay uh
what about uh what is happening in
Philadelphia why is every other video
every video I see of something awful
like some type of execution or some like
robbery and broad daylight yesterday
morning top of my Twitter feed with some
Mom some ring doorbell camera some mom
she's getting her kids ready she's like
is Suburban mom getting her kids into
the minivan and some dude carjacks are
with their kids in any man and he had
like a handgun with a 50 round drum in
it or something yo some ridiculous
weapon I that as a parent I got two
little girls like as a parent that is uh
that is like uh it's hard to think of
something worse than that actually
someone like grabbing my car keys and
running away with my kids dude we used
to play at the park around the corner
from my house growing up this is like a
1980s 19 early 90s and we just go
there'd be like four kids age nine to
eleven playing on the swing set no
parents I was just thinking a couple
nights ago how how in the modern day to
consider letting your kids go off for
hours a time like well first of all I
can't constantly be watching the kids 24
7. so yeah they're gonna be off on their
own but like and they yeah there's a
fence around the backyard but like can
they go to the park I don't know I was
in a suburb but even today like what
state Ohio Chicago Falls Ohio no it's
getting crazy now there's a bunch of
story there was one story I read about
uh a mom had Child Protective Services
called on her because her kid was
playing in the front yard by himself and
it was like seven years old when I was
seven I was gone I was out it's like
come back when the street lights come on
I can handle like woke trash like
Protective Service crap but but it's the
crime it's that that someone would get
carjacked in their driveway is that
where the mom was in her driveway
driveway you can see the ring doorbell
cameras you know I I'm not I don't have
it in front of me are they legally
allowed to carry in in that area in
Philadelphia no way that's freaking
crazy no way that's like that's like a
Revolt waiting to happen this is why Dr
Oz I mean like might actually might
actually win do you guys you guys see
the latest uh crazy crime video out of
New York The Daily Mail Stark naked man
goes nuts at you and square subway
station and NYC as MTA officials
struggle to get him to calm down before
he runs into pack subway cars I'm not
going to show the video yikes but this
is just like the latest in a series of
videos there's like a video of a lady
getting pushed under the subway tracks
there's videos of like people being shot
and mugged it's just like the amount of
content coming out of New York or or
video footage of all of these crimes in
the escalation it's Bonkers yeah it's
like it's like living in a world star
hip hop in real life instead of just
seeing it online you have to deal with
it every single day there's no
accountability anymore yeah there's no
there's no fear that's missing well it
used to feel like if you step out of
line the cops are going to grab you or
someone's going to shoot you now it's
like what where's the out of line what
where's the response where's the
protection what's the what's the point
of government why would you want to be a
cop at these cities why the entire
system of the city is designed to
backstab you so here's a great story
from Capitol Hill Washington DC we have
a cop I won't name him he's our neighbor
all right so he's down the street at the
end of the block uh nice little house
little American flag outside good cop
great cop during the BLM uh riots uh he
broke his leg chasing after some some
some perp and he breaks his leg jumps a
fence breaks his leg and so he's had a
lot of time on the couch like chat with
us about what the police force is like
in DC and through that time uh they
could not recruit to like fill the
chairs inside of their Academy like even
halfway you couldn't get any comps no
one wanted to be a cop no one still
wants to be a cop in Washington DC this
particular police officer is looking for
any opportunity Unity to get out
possible now some of them want to
migrate to places like Florida where
police officers are respected and even
paid by Ron DeSantis you get a five
thousand dollar bonus if you're a cop
that moves Florida and that makes
Florida a very safe place you ask where
do these communities exist I would argue
maybe the Midwest I was just back in
Iowa I was very nice also in Florida it
is wild I like I go through our
neighborhood and I my wife's gonna kill
me because we think this is a nice best
kept secret but like it's like you're
back in a Norman Rockwell painting it's
like the society functions people walk
their dogs kids do play in the street
and run around the neighborhood by
themselves it's it's it's nuts and now
the mayor of Tampa is a former police
officer and she's a very like she's her
name's Jane kaster she's a very Law and
Order you know no riots here no no no
antifa here right no BLM
looting here
but I I like I saw like I saw it break
down in in Washington DC with my cop
friend and you feel really bad about
them because suddenly you're like I'm
gonna be the last guy holding the bag
I'm gonna be the last I'm gonna be the
only guy on call like that cop in New
Orleans who is the only guy on call
and and he quit on the spot because he
like looks onto his recorder there
little machine he's like I'm the only
person responding to all of to all these
call-ins and he and you know he quit I
you know he he did a Twitter thread on
it it's it's so terrible for these
police officers and these communities
that don't support them they're gonna
get what's coming to him which is what
you're talking about they gotta get rid
of this Mass crap too because people mob
going into stores with masks on is no
good they have cameras there for
security if you can't see who it is
that's a big danger it used to be
illegal to go into private organizations
with a mask on because it was a thread
well you should have privacy in my
opinion but all the same not in my
public a sad but not in my private
establishment you're not you're gonna
reveal who you are but if you before you
come in there you can make it you can
yeah that's up to them yeah on your
private property you can do whatever you
want but I still think you know the
government shouldn't be watching and
surveilling every single the private
company should be surveilling the people
that are coming in to buy stuff and they
and if they don't want mass then they
don't get to take your mask off before
you come into my store I want to see
your face I want to know who who I have
to go after if you're going to mess with
me
yeah the government mandated masks in a
lot of these circumstances so you
couldn't do that so that's that needs to
be repealed now that we know that
covet's done according to Joe Biden well
assuming Joe Biden is correct pandemic
his quote we all said that video is like
I think it was at a Philly as well where
they raid the Wawa they all storm in and
they're smashing everything and then the
chick jumps up and thinks that's
twerking and people are just just
destroying everything for no reason yeah
I think we still got to be careful
calling for more police more
centralization of power more government
because look at what the government's
doing right now look what the cops are
doing right now criminals Psychopaths
robbers
they go to jail they get released from
jail political thought criminals stay in
jail heavily prosecuted heavily punished
and if you only enforce that system and
you give it more of your power and
authority and money I think the
situation is only going to be worse for
the average American uh so so I I think
we need do need to bring up George Soros
and how he financed a lot of the woke
District Attorneys all throughout the
United States that have implemented a
lot of these policies that punish People
based on their political ideology rather
than of course the severity of their
crime I think what we have seen is
deliberate I think it is order out of
chaos and I think the larger turnaround
here is people going to be like more
government more government more
government more police and then I think
that that could be used against a lot of
the people calling for it in my own
personal opinion from my own kind of
conspiracy mindset yeah I like arming
the population as opposed to creating
more police yeah personal responsibility
giving people more rights given giving
people the ability to to defend
themselves I think is a lot more
important to call for or rather than
more police more centralization more
government more money towards the state
which they're going to be abusing and
using in the worst case scenario against
the average American because if you look
at who the government is serving it's
not you they're not looking for your
best interest they're not here to really
protect and serve very few officers the
few should be commended should be
promoted should be respected but very
few officers actually live by that
notion of protecting and serving serving
a lot of them are here to give you
tickets and generate revenue for the
state and we just have to in my opinion
be a little bit careful when it comes to
more and more and more in in that
retrospect calling for for that one more
guns
more personal responsibility more
freedom more Liberty and more Firearms
sure I think that would work out better
in my personal opinion and there would
be there would be a lot more uh there
would be a lot less uh harm reduction I
saw video game developers are now making
the gun when you what they call it
flagging if you point a gun at someone
when you're walking around with it they
call it flagging so you should never do
that no of course and in video games up
until now when you run your gun's always
pointing forward so you like and kids
are doing this whether or not they're
getting indoctrinated to think it's fine
to point a weapon maybe Alec Baldwin
forgot but you're supposed to the
developers are having the guns pointed
down now when you point at someone or
point it up and away when you're aiming
and then as soon as you move past them
you can set the gun back down that's
important man because we're brainwashing
kids with this stuff and we need to stop
that wasn't a gun responsibility that
was like Ian is just sitting here having
a conversation and then very very
quickly spun around to slap Alec Baldwin
in the face and go right back to a very
serious he killed Helena Hutchins and I
wonder what's if her family's gonna like
we need to make sure the kids are
playing the games and their guns are
ready Alec Baldwin by the way is a
murderer Baldwin said it's an example a
really bad example for people in the
film and television industry so like
Baldwin killed more people than every
single Rider on January
yeah yeah he should be charged and uh uh
whatever man I we talked a lot about the
Alec Baldwin stuff he pointed a gun at
somebody pulled the trigger he pulled
the hammer he pulled the trigger went
off it killed her just can't be sloppy
with guns it's easy to learn how to
shoot in the modern age I don't know I
just think it's ridiculous there's this
whole excuse where it's like but he was
on a movie
and it's like you can't commit a crime
but I was in a movie you know what I
mean like so the armorer uh you talk
about Jeremy boring daily wire released
a uh very cool uh movie called Terror on
the Prairie right and so we went there
and there was an armor I don't know any
armorers right Hollywood armor but there
was a dude there they shoot a lot of
guns in this movie Gino Carano uh was in
the movie anyway uh that this is the
first time I met an armorer like oh this
is cool Alec Baldwin immediately said oh
my God I figured that I get asked this
everywhere in the airport at the
supermarket everyone finds out what I do
and they ask me about Alec Baldwin and
I'm gonna tell you exactly what happened
because I know what happened I know for
a fact there's a small community of
people who do this I know exactly what
happened this is the story about Alec
Baldwin this is what this armor armorer
said to me I hope I don't get anyone
fired here he said what happens is on
these movie sets a lot of sitting around
and waiting people get bored and the
armors like to actually mess around with
guns and do target practice and so they
put live rounds in the guns they are
real guns a lot of them and they they
have to look real and they have to act
real in some scenes they have to
actually do shoot they have to shoot
they have to physically shoot and so the
the armors like you know to make to to
make the time pass they actually do
target practice with these things
and he says this armor says they left
around live around in there um
and they handed it to Alec Baldwin and
Alec Baldwin pulled the trigger and
killed it I'm not saying in any universe
that Alec Baldwin should not be held
accountable for this but he said that
there was a projectile left in the gun
and that that projectile was just lazy
like someone being lazy someone being
bored on the set put a live round except
he uh apparently he had pulled the gun
out and pulled the hammer back several
times meaning this revolver the the live
round was in the last in rotation which
means because the the shot required the
dummy rounds to be in it so it looked
like it was loaded someone put in a
bunch of rounds maybe they opened it up
saw one and then filled it with the
dummy ones not realizing I'd imagine
they'd look different maybe they didn't
maybe they all look the same maybe
that's possible but I just look at that
and I'm like we have to make assumptions
about how it could have happened as
opposed to The Simple Solution which
which is Alec Baldwin
put a bullet in it yes yeah don't be
afraid of the gun I don't want this
story this Alec Baldwin sort of freak
people out about guns he did a horrible
um just like a a very irresponsible
thing and it's not the gun's fault if
you check the weapon it functions as
intended Alec Baldwin man did he put a
sour taste in people's mouths for
weapons and I just not in today's
culture we need more responsibility with
weapons less fear about weapons more
self-control my whole point on the whole
Alec Baldwin things it's come up
bracelet because now he might be charged
it's just they're like calculate how
many data points each story requires
let's say it was the armorers were doing
shooting practice and then they made a
mistake you have a whole bunch of
different points in this story they have
to line up to make this possible you
also have Alec Baldwin fighting with
crew and then shooting a woman and I'm
like the least amount of assumptions is
Alec Baldwin fights with crew member
later shoots kills crew member as
opposed to Alec Baldwin fights with crew
member doesn't think twice about it go
wasn't as private meeting with her
doesn't think twice about it someone
else takes gone doing target practice
then someone else goes to load gun and
accidentally puts live bullet only in
the last Chambers you know position then
puts the dummy rounds in the rest then
gives it Alec Baldwin who with 40 Years
of weapons experience doesn't check and
then points a moment he was fighting
with pulls up that hammer back several
times and then finally kills her and I'm
just like there's just way too much
there so you're saying there's malice
here you think that Alec Baldwin
intended to kill her so a bunch of the
reporting was that he had been fighting
with crew members and crew were starting
to walk off and then there was an
interview he gave where he was calling
her like Intense or something like not
not saying anything very favorable or he
had a meeting with her and apparently
that he tried he tried saying it first
he wasn't friends with him later he was
friends with her or something like that
it's been a while since we covered all
the details of the story but I'm just
saying that to have a story that
involves the armorer some crew doing
shooting practice the armor like Alec
Baldwin And The Angry crew
you have a very circuitous plot about
framing Alec Baldwin or a potential
accident which requires you know getting
10 numbers correct in a row versus Alec
Baldwin did not have kind words with her
the crew was starting to walk off the
state the set and then Alec Baldwin shot
and killed her so it's like the big the
big point for me on this one is that
Alec Baldwin has training on firearms
and to be handed a weapon and back you
got it bang whoops it's like in what he
he made the argument that he's not
allowed to check firearms and hand it to
him
because it's not a bad point it's a good
defense he said if I'm handing a gun and
then I open it up and start fidgeting
with it they're going to take it from me
what did you just do to it we checked it
to make sure it was safe so when they
give you the gun you just point and
shoot at people and my argument there is
no way no you check it with the armor
right two of you together and then and
and you're with them and they open it up
and they show you the rounds and they
say these are the rounds we got them
from this box we're putting them in and
then they should probably cycle them if
they're dummies and then open it again
close it hand it to the actor to do the
scene but Alec Baldwin is hubris with
four years experience felt Untouchable
you probably haven't had a drinking the
night before maybe not but brain fog
didn't care was pissed off at Helena
because he didn't like her anyway just
totally lazy I don't know if I believe
it chaos and destruction let's jump to
this next story and just get silly from
Rolling Stone from the Trump supporter
who called slavery a choice Kanye West
wears white lives matter t-shirt Candace
Owens matched racist shirts with rapper
how's that racist racist huh what they
the live stream event saw the music
wearing the shirt as he laid back and
recorded children seemingly from his
donda Academy along with his daughter
North walking around in a circle and all
black as they sang you make forever oh
and conservative Candace Owens even
posed for a photo with West wearing a
matching shirt with a slogan white
supremacists such as the KKK and the
Aryan resistance Society have overtaken
the black lives matter phrase by black
people protesting to play Battalion
reframed it made a defamation league has
categorized the phrase as a hate slogan
well what do you do now when there's two
black people wearing it is it still a
white supremacist thing I don't I don't
know if I who gets to say I think it's a
joke at that point Anderson doesn't mean
it can't be racist Anderson Anderson
Cooper gets to say the corporate media
will of course say whatever they want to
say uh but but this is you know a slogan
that a lot of law enforcement including
the Federal Bureau of Investigations
investigated a lot of people for for
saying uh people were interrogated for
for saying this slogan in colleges and
the ADL also goes after this particular
saying as well so again it all depends
on who controls the narrative who
controls the conversation and yeah I
mean I think they'll label it whatever
they want to label it I think the best
troll was when 4chan I think it was
4chan came up with that sign it said
it's okay to be white yeah and it was
the most generic it was a blank piece of
paper with very basic writings that it's
okay to be white like not even a good
not even it was better or was it good or
just it's okay and they called it white
supremacy like if you literally just
said it was okay to be white they called
you a white Supreme assist but that was
the point of the troll to expose that
there was no degree that they would
allow you to be a white person and live
in peace yeah that was the correct
slogan I got it I got the slogan mixed
up I thought it was the slogan that
Kanye was saying but it was actually the
slogan that you mentioned that in Ohio
University had the FBI involved in an
investigation because someone put up a
sign saying it's okay to be white uh so
you know the feds are keeping a close
eye on this and the corporate media is
of course weaponizing this term to mean
whatever they want it to mean and of
course changing the the real definitions
of it I was getting when I was admitting
Minds in like 2016 2017 after Trump got
elected there all of a sudden became a
lot of racism online right after Trump I
think he said some racist stuff in his
campaign and people felt like that was
the floodgates had been opened and they
were allowed to be racist now what did
he say what did he say yeah
um
he talked about Mexicans like they were
like their own unoffice
he did say that he was calling for a uh
oh yeah Muslim a travel ban which was
that's a religion not racist yeah but
it's so it's a similar like xenophobia
kind of thing appeared and uh I used to
get a lot of white Purity stuff like
it's okay to be white white Purity then
there'd be like an old like Galax white
kind of Nazi we were just talking about
how it's okay to be white as a kind of a
banal statement yeah I would get
overloaded with it in my
administratorship I'd get these just
it's okay to be white it's okay to be
white white priv like white is beautiful
and it's like yeah it's it's racist
whether or not it's hateful I don't know
but it's definitely like you could tell
it wasn't just people expressing their
love for being white it was like they
were trying to dig in on it so I get why
they're treating it like that I don't
agree that it's a hate a hate tactic but
I see why no the point of it's okay to
be white as a saying was to prove that
even saying something as mediocre as
that would result in your exact reaction
right now calling it racist yeah
because they're picking a race and
they're making a generalization it's
okay it's okay to be white I'm saying
like I love black women that's a racist
statement that's not just a race it's
proving the point of the meme right now
your reaction they didn't say anything
good or bad it's okay there's Big R
racism which is like systemic hateful
like they're my race is better than that
race then there's little our racism
where you're just talking about race
it's just a racist conversation like
it's okay to have a racist conversation
as long as you're not like systemically
racist you know what I'm saying changing
the definition of word there's two
different ways to be racist and one is
like the hateful one that everyone's
trying to avoid then the other one is
like you pick out a race and you make
all these generalizations about it but
that's not what it's okay to be white
was that was they were just generalizing
like it's okay to be this race and it's
like I get it it is but they weren't
just you know it wasn't it wasn't
improving the point you're proving the
name right what's what's the point what
if it was another race it would have
been exactly the same same as right if
it's okay to be Indian it's okay to be
Chinese like it's you know but it is
okay to be Indian it is okay it's also
generally a racist statement but it is
okay oh is it racist because you're
talking about race and you're making a
generalization about it
I thought thought for you thought for
you you're from Chicago right
probably the biggest holiday in Chicago
they turn the river green that's right
there's a day called St Patrick's Day
and and that day there are shirts that
say Kiss Me I'm Irish or everyone's
Irish today is that racist well it's
natural to say so
it's Nationalist and like that that's
also weird distinction like African
doesn't mean black you know Irish
doesn't mean white so like race and
nationality are kind of different is
Elon Musk an African-American
technically yeah literally yeah I don't
know what else what is what are you
supposed to say to it like if the
argument is that race is social
construct because the color of your skin
varies among cultures then Elon Musk
being from Africa would be an
African-American by that argument and
Luke apparently according to a group
called The Coalition of communities of
color Luke with blue eyes and blonde
hair is a person of color I am sorry by
definition
peach pink yellowish color
so am I okay to be a person of color Ian
you certainly are Luke oh that was
racist that's racist but I was
just games I didn't know there's had
anything to do with the race so no no
for real there's an organization that
said Slavic people are people of color
so Luke being from Poland is it's a big
I think that's what Hitler thought I
mean did he not did he not think they
were like inferior people yeah yeah yeah
the Polish there's like chapters about
this yeah this is so weird the Germans
didn't like the Polish nope not at all
yeah is it the Russian Superior for that
one nope yeah I want to like detach
people from being I don't want people to
feel afraid to talk about race like it's
important that we talk about race and
like genetic differences it's because
there are genetic differences in humans
historically because our ancestors lived
in different areas with different
climates their bodies evolved
differently and it's interesting that is
still racial if not small are racist
conversations to be like these this
genetic type of person tends to be
taller this genetic type of person tends
to be able to do math faster because of
some you know you can see if it maybe
it's a genetic issue as well as like a a
cultural thing that's fine as long as
you don't start saying this one's better
than that one which is the the actual
definition of racism here at Miriam
Webster that
race leads is the fundamental
determinant of a human trait and
capacity that racial differences produce
an inherent superiority of a particular
race that is the Miriam Webster number
one definition on Google search of a
racism right but I think Polish people
cook cabbage better than Americans so is
that racist no I think that's just like
cultures doing things better there's
some cultures that do things about world
never history of utilizing cabbage yo
skin color comes skin color is just a
function of where your ancestors came
from and how close they were to the
equator because melanin is just
something that your body naturally
produces based on how much sunlight you
get and it is a protective it's less
about like if you want to hear some
biology than anything it's more about
the The Wonder of the design of your
body to protect you from a lot of UV
light make sure that you can like up
that you're not gonna be harmed by all
right the amount of UV light that your
ancestors were from all right this crazy
thing about black frogs in uh Ukraine
and uh it's because of Chernobyl so what
happened is frog the frogs were green
most of them but there were some that
had darker skin when the radiation leak
came out the green skin frogs all
started dying the melanin in the black
frogs because they're like dark brown
dark black was a was dissipating the
radioactive energy and so they were more
likely to survive wow so 20 some odd
years on they reproduced in the whole
area around Chernobyl is populated by
black frogs wow yeah that's crazy this
is wrong man this is why even like the
term white doesn't quite make any sense
what do you mean by white like what like
what color white right like what color
what what do you mean color if you if
your white person moves down to Mexico
City as you said and uh a hipster who is
like translucent from you know like the
Upper East Side goes to Mexico City they
will develop a tan over time their skin
will become darker they will have a
different in 10 years man living in
Mexico City they will have a different
complexion entirely they won't even look
like the same person and that's just the
Wonder of the body and your body
protecting itself and making sure you
don't get skin cancer and you'll get
sunburned all day I wonder if that that
melanin study and radioactivity would
mean that white people are less less uh
likely to survive radioactive fallout
interesting yeah that's bringing it full
circle that was impressive if you had a
video game where you could be like all
right we need to deal with certain
things what race of person am I going to
send in to deal with that because they
can handle that situation better I need
people to be I need people to be like um
camouflage in the ice all right I'm
gonna pick a white person I need people
to be camouflaged at night or I'll pick
a black person and of course no one's
white or black but their Skin's more
likely to blend in with the surroundings
or you could love it or or they could
use face paint and I tell you humans are
phenomenal I don't care what skin color
you got for where you're from you have
the ability to change the world man and
learn stuff that no one else has learned
way to go yes and that's why that's why
the definition of racism is saying that
one race is better than the other not
saying that it's okay to be a race well
what about just making generalizations
inherently racist
it's okay to be Indian too in Chinese
but I think it I guess it's we're using
different definitions of the word race
which obviously there are racism rather
because if you just make a
generalization about a race this is
something I learned growing up I'd be
like oh people be like I love black
black women are so beautiful and I'd be
like well that's racist you know you're
making a generalization about black
people black women and they're like I I
guess technically and then we laugh
because it's like yeah I assume you're
saying but saying it's okay to be a race
isn't racist because you're not
generalizing on anybody you're just
saying like yeah it's okay it's like
it's actually the opposite of racism
it's saying like it's it's it's okay
it's preference no it's it's not even
that it's just like it would be racist
to be like it's not okay to be white
that would be racist but being like no
it's it's like we are tolerant and
accepting of other races that's not
racist that's the opposite of it
I think once you start talking about
race like that you're you're basically
creating a racist conversation
so maybe not Big R maybe not like
hatefully but so what if someone said
it's not okay to be white is that racist
yeah I think so there's no there's no
circumstance like if you start bringing
white and black and skin color and stuff
into conversations you're being a ray
you're you're you're now a racist
Converse it's a racist conversation no
but it's not the same definition of the
hateful like you know xenophobia kind of
crap
do we used to be so obsessed with Race
So speaking of Chicago I grew up with
the Michael Jordan poster on my wall I
think I was aware that he was a
different skin color than me but it
didn't really matter I idealized the guy
I think it was really great I had his
jersey like I I think I was great his
his poster along with Shaquille O'Neal's
poster hung on my wall and never once
did I think like that's cool because
because of their school they say that's
white privilege the fact that you didn't
have to think about it proves that you
had privilege
but I was saying these guys are like
pretty great for us these people don't
seem to have a good logic behind what
their ideology is I definitely noticed
it when I was like it felt like in the
90s there was like a different
conversation about I think maybe no one
was having a conversation about race you
can check the term racism in the New
York Times and how they use it and it's
like skyrocketed since around when Rocky
Wall Street yep since I lost you
we were pretty racist growing up and
they called it Caucasian Falls where I'm
from it was like 99 white kids and like
uh it was really gross and I didn't know
any better like we just grew up like if
the stuff we said when I was 12 was on
the internet I'd still be humiliated
like it would still be like haunting me
to this day and I had to learn like yo I
would make jokes about gay people it was
just like effeminate jokes and stuff and
then in college I went to theater school
and they're like you know that's really
offensive Ian and so I stopped and I was
like you know but that was raised in a
really racist environment when I went to
South America I noticed that I looked
different than people and that was what
Tim's saying about white privilege is
the privilege of looking like the
majority of the people around you like
skin tone because when their skin was
dark they look at me and they'd be like
Thor you know they would say they would
look at me and like you look like Thor
from the movie oh I'm gonna make a shirt
with you on it that says Thor yeah Chris
Hemsworth you have great hair thanks sir
when uh when I traveled around most
places I never experienced that because
everywhere I go no one can tell what I
am so I remember this one story uh that
I've told before when I was in Egypt and
I'm in the I'm in the back of this with
this van with a bunch of Egyptians and
the vice producer I'm with is this white
dude with brown hair and blue eyes and
he looks over to me and he's like okay
Tim
we're gonna play it cool we're gonna
listen to what our our fixtures tell us
to do because once we get out there
ain't no one gonna believe we're not a
couple of white guys and every single
Egyptian ghost no Tim looks Egyptian and
I was like oh really they're like yeah
yeah especially with the hat because
people wear hats like that so they were
like no no you should come and I went to
Nasser city where the Muslim Brotherhood
was
no problem in fact one guy even came up
one guy even came up to me started
yelling something in Arabic and I just
like smiled and then the guy I was with
started answering him in Arabic and then
as we walked away started laughing and
he was like dude he thought you were
like like a monk or an Imam or something
because you're wearing the Hat he was
asking where the mosque was and I was
like really the same hat not the same
hat but similar style beanie and uh you
know I've been to South America
typically when I go to a lot of places
people can't tell you know so I just
kind of like drift about what what is
your what is your hair I mean German
Irish Korean Japanese especially if
everyone on Earth had a baby it would
look like you but your skin would be a
little darker if your skin gets yeah if
your skin got a little darker that's
like the future of humanity when
everybody starts except here's the thing
most woke liberals don't think I'm white
they think I'm not white until until it
becomes politically expedient but it's
like the weirdest thing because if it's
white people who think I'm not white I
don't worry about anything because
they're not racist to me and then when I
go to other countries and they just
think I fit in with their country then I
don't got to worry about it because even
if they are racist they think I'm same
as them you know it's weird how that
works did you ever feel uh like people
tell me stories about Egypt and they say
like it's uncomfortable there and that
it's not like that nice of a place is it
true I don't know I had a blast yeah
yeah I mean it was it was a revolution
happening so but I went to the mall
walked around totally normal it was cool
um inexpensive yeah like the the guy I
was with told me to shut up because we
went to a fast food restaurant when I
found out I was like a dollar for a meal
I was like whoa and it was like shhh
he's like this is a lot of money to
these people he's like you're American
you're something like a like a like an
a-hole and I was like oh whoa you're
right man that was bad I shouldn't do
that but I was like really excited
because I could get food and I was kind
of broke and I was like this is amazing
and then you know to them they were like
Rich American shows up
not people aren't going to be too happy
with that but I think the guy I was with
got like attacked in an alley because he
did look like a white American dude he
got surrounded and then some other dude
came up and started getting the guys to
back away and like told him not to do it
and they were like I guess once they
what the the there's a bunch of Egyptian
guys got in the face of the vice
producer and like cornered him
and then some other guy came up and was
basically saying in Arabic or something
like you're gonna attack an American
journalist you're gonna make us all look
bad it's going to hurt us you got to
stop and then got him and then he put
his hand up and then looked at the
producer was like go now
it's crazy stuff man getting out there
all right we're gonna go super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you at 11 PM you
don't want to miss it but for now smash
the like button let's read
Raymond g Stanley Jr says what's he
doing no Luke stop uh for those that saw
the show on Friday
on that one uh no we have to we can't be
fake news all right Luke wasn't doing
anything nope that was it he was doing
literally nothing he was just pretending
like he was into something we went with
it we turned the camera you know how the
sausages man that's it that's it it was
just a gag because Luke didn't have a
gag left
all right trip sucks says regarding your
member segment I'm a film teacher
Moonlight was the best film of the 2010s
it's not woke just a great film absolute
Masterpiece oh interesting yeah we
talked about movies that's cool
we got Raymond g again he says everyone
who isn't an Ian phobic weirdo should go
see cast Kessel you'll have a graphene
time especially for free the code and
the FED folks who DMT know the union
election was rigged go antifa Bros
yes Ian's fake Union election
the allegation is that it was rigged
watch cast Castle to find out more
wait is it was that a historical
election
yeah lco Sr fio says not a single word
in the Brazilian election Tim we're
still waiting to see what happens the
polls were wrong uh bolsonaro didn't
lose yet but it's not looking good
that's about it I don't know what else
is going we gotta run off next I think
yeah yeah the polls were saying that I
was at Lula yeah that is his name is uh
is it a guy or it's a guy who's a guy
yeah they said he was going to win and
then he got just short of 50 so not
enough and now there's gonna be a runoff
and it's gonna go to bolsonaro and Lula
I'm not saying like Okay so I'm not
saying I follow this closely I don't
speak Portuguese I'm not an expert on
this however Steve Bannon was on a show
today saying This is really strange
because bolsonaro's party is winning
huge down ballot yep and their
candidates are doing very very well all
the way down the ballot and then he's
doing poorly right so I don't know
enough I don't know enough enough about
Brazilian politics but I do have a
friend who's Brazilian who
the general idea I get is
at least from from conversations I've
had they don't like him as much as they
like the politics so it might be like a
trump DeSantis kind of thing where you
know uh Trump himself as a personality
Riles a lot of people up but the
candidates have a lot of but the rest of
the candidates may be more tactful or
something like that or who knows I don't
know what the politics are like in
Brazil there could be corruption and
other nonsense we'll see what happens I
don't know are they using voting
machines like proprietary voting
machines I heard mail-in ballots
in Brazil
we'll see I mean the the benefit of a
runoff is that they have a chance now to
before the final tally see what's going
on if they have questions they better
address them now
all right all right let's grab some more
super jets
what do we got here
Victor Solano says it's still in the
Arctic around some islands look at the
New York Post they do talk about the
submarine that's the Poseidon submarine
Brandon Hampton says Tim the noise your
computer keeps making is the alphabet
boys spying on you through your computer
no we figured out what it was got a new
email system and it dings every time you
get an email oh is that what's happening
but where was the sound coming from um
it was for coming from this TV TV yeah I
know yeah that's weird
what do we got here Charlie Wilson says
shout out to my co-worker Haley who left
me speechless when she asked if I knew
what Tim cast was when I mentioned
listening to Joe Rogan wow shout out to
Haley thanks thanks for shouting us out
and uh spreading the word but apparently
Charlie uh already knew what it was so
you'll have to spread the word more now
further
Marshall P says tsunami nukes are not
new and were tested right after World
War II with USA and New Zealand tests
they the tests found that they don't
work very well unless Russia's is better
what if it turned out since every
hurricane since the Cold War has been
Russian nuclear hurricanes
we just bat out a century later I don't
know uh that conspiracy theories that
harp is firing energy into the
atmosphere to create storms or something
like that well they they do uh modify
the weather the Chinese government
openly admits that but you know it's not
about admitting hold on it's not about
admitting it because that implies it's
like a secret uh so they brag about it
silver iodide Cloud seeding's been
around since what like the 60s and
Germany's been doing infrared laser
cloud seating for a long time weather
manipulation has been around for a long
time it's it's not like they're creating
tornadoes and blowing people up I don't
know about that those hurricane eyes I
was like there's got to be something
magnetic in space that it created like
that like some sort of magnetic
charge must be causing that maybe
similar tornadoes I don't know but
that's you know
Tim Jake says the tsunami bomb is the
latest iteration of geophysical Warfare
New York Times reported on it in the
early 70s one scenario was five nukes
detonated simultaneously in the Pacific
causing a wave that could Wipe Out the
West Coast
that'd be crazy or they could send a
team to the Center of the Earth with
nukes to detonate them to start up the
court of spin again like in the court oh
yeah yeah with Aaron Eckhart and Stanley
Tucci who else is in that movie
let's find out I don't know regret it
now
Brett dasovic Sensei says nuke Dubuque
we puke
I'm from Iowa I've been in Dubuque many
times yeah yeah High School football in
Dubuque solid yep cool um City because
it's right up on the riverbed this is
interesting some hygiene says someone
please ask Alex ask Alex Jones if the
aliens will interrupt or prevent a
global nuclear war there's a conspiracy
theory that aliens shut off a bunch of
nukes
and so uh people have been saying for
the past few years the next thing that
happened is going to be aliens right
that was a big meme for a while yeah
then there was like the storm Area 51
stuff fears back maybe Vladimir Putin's
gonna like hit the button the nuke's
gonna go up and then the aliens will
appear what if Vladimir Putin is the
alien he kind of looks like an alien
he's short he proves it he's got bug
eyes
let's grab some more
Joe Dutchman says read the James Bond
virus imagine a virus that's designed to
primarily Target those who are obese
older and have multiple medical issues
weird that would be crazy like you know
like calling a certain group of people
would be nuts
are looking at each other I'm like what
can I say here without getting a show in
trouble Erin gaming news says did you
know Canada has Chinese police stations
we did talk about this a little bit
there's also one in the United States
did you know that Benny China opened
police stations in Europe Canada and one
in New York so it's not legal of course
right you don't do this that's right but
like that's a second government
unelected that's a second government
institution operating here in violation
of our laws uh I believe yes yep that's
crazy isn't it
are there any is there any statistics or
data out of this in in Manhattan with
this police office one and then two like
you know are they arresting like
Americans today like are they
threatening American citizens yes they
claim it's for their own citizens but if
someone's like a dual citizen then
they're gonna treat them like a citizen
of China but this is basically them
operating illegal apparatus in our
country which is just absolutely insane
so there's a homie uh story that we've
covered a couple years back there's a
homie at the University of Minnesota
right Chinese I was pointing at uh Alx
our executive producer who's awesome and
everyone should go follow uh Alx the
Lord on Truth social
um Instagram and getter uh there's a
homie University of Minnesota it's
Chinese National and he tweeted about Xi
Jinping he tweeted a meme that he's Pooh
Bear and he got put in jail what he got
his ass got dragged back to China and he
got thrown in the clink in China how did
they get this jail they I
but according to the article that I read
it was uh they use his family they went
out for his family they were like okay
well your mother no longer has a job and
your father's going to be uh in the
bread lines and you know your family is
now because of what you've done here in
America so somebody was monitoring his
treats he's at the University of
Minnesota this is a this is a uh
well-reported story University of
Minnesota student Chinese tweets Pooh
Bear meme about G gets uh put in jail
well let's brought home Let's do let's
just be honest I mean Xi Jinping is the
the greatest leader his Charisma is just
exudes from his person and uh we would
be honored to be in his presence and
even be uh even one-tenth as amazing as
he is
I think it's funny how everything is I
said is actually like to anybody who
understands the language would know that
I was saying the most awful things
possible about him that's funny how
language works right but you know when
uh when Joe Biden eventually eventually
hands the keys over you know to to China
I said good things about it you mean
when he's in the ignition when
when she comes to collect
he'll be like he'll come in here and
look at everybody and be like I forgot
we're all bad he said nice things about
me
and then you know I'll get to I'll get
to hang out I feel good in his presence
man
you feel good no we should all post
memes of she has Winnie the Pooh we
should support Joe Biden too because
having a decrepit president's not good
for anybody right now well they can't
deny even The Daily Beast wrote that his
brain's broken when that happened I was
like whoa The Daily Beast yikes yeah we
need to support that dude no one can
deny it anymore
cringe Inc says the episode you speak of
was a poison developer who used Gene
specific poisons they found the culprit
because he always inserted a useless
molecule into the poison in the shape of
a seahorse as a calling card for credit
was that The Fringe one hmm
I what was it was that remember when
they talked about doing a gay bomb was
that real
do you guys I believe that was during
the Vietnam war they were doing research
and development into it and then
concluded that they shouldn't go forward
with this but uh you you could uh
obviously like it worked and
hypothetical uh you know references it's
not it's not unfeasible like it there's
a big probability that they I think they
did have it and I think they tried to
get to release it in Vietnam I got to
fact check myself like a bomb that makes
people get yes yeah but they but they
but I think they didn't use it because
they found that the soldiers would be
fighting for for their lovers more
intensely uh instead of just
passionately making love and dropping
their weapons so they did turn the frogs
gay well if they had gay bombs since the
Vietnam Wars I don't know about they but
you know that story is true right
yes
so Alex of course was being silly but
atrazine was a chemical that studies
found was disrupting the endocrine
systems of frogs and turning them
hermaphroditic so Jones yells her
turning the freaking frogs gay and then
the media is like Jones thinks frogs are
gay when in reality he was just being
hyperbolic and silly about an actual
story Daily Mail 2017 2007 from October
this is their title scientists developed
gay bomb to make enemy soldiers stop
fighting and make love yep Daily Mail
there's a reporting on this also known
as the halitosis bomb formal for two
non-lethal psychochemical weapons the
United States Air Force research
laboratory speculated about producing uh
theories involved discharging sex
pheromones over enemy forces in order to
make them sexually attracted to each
other
thank you you know what that's from
Wikipedia by the way I don't know if
that's real or not I just can't believe
that's real the halitosis it's like two
guys who are best friends and they're
like fighting and there's like a sniper
shooting at him and also there's like a
big pink explore lotion and then he's
just like I can't fight anymore I need
to love you and I believe it what they
don't sell SD I'm like do you ever see
the videos of the British soldiers and
climbing trees and they're like they
wouldn't Focus so they stopped testing
at all MK Ultra mind control CIA
projects giving unsuspecting people you
know acid with them but what if they
just did that what if they did like an
LSD bomb and then the enemy soldiers
would just be like looped out of their
minds you know
yeah some people don't find themselves
loopy some people find themselves more
focused and more attentive and more
aware of situations and things
um because it depends on the stream
plane flies over the enemy troops and a
blanket of smoke just goes all over them
and they're like what's happening and
they're eating munchies and being lazy
with Cheeto dust yeah they all turn to
Ian and they call it agent orange is
what they call that place yeah okay I
thank you all right Tyler B says the
animal transformation virus is the plot
of the anime brand new animal lol it was
released by the government of animal
people
what animal brand new animal Benny if
you were transformed into an animal what
would have you so I asked him this and I
didn't get an uh a response and I insist
on a response before okay I have no idea
everyone's blowing the I'm watching the
comment section right now they're
melting down wanting to know what animal
yeah there's a hundred uh a gorilla I
guess yes nasty well but that's you know
the Tim cast meme is yeah Alex Jones
came in here and said I'm a gorilla so I
guess I'll just say gorilla all right
gorilla I guess everybody could be a
gorilla I'd be a woman well so Alex kept
coming here saying I am a gorilla so we
made I am a gorilla t-shirts and so it's
a t it's a gorilla and you know going
like I'm a gorilla what about you Ben
parakeet is this like what
I even turned into an animal in Wartime
like is this something that's being used
like tonight like you leave and it's
just like it's happening
I mean I go to the zoo a lot in Tampa
with my kids monkeys are very cool not
trying to copy but like the monkey
pictures
oh yeah with uh who's that actor
Justin long it's a Kevin Smith movie
where a kid a guy gets kidnapped well he
goes to visit some writer or something
and then the guy beats him and
surgically turns him into a walrus like
trans walrus or something what the heck
it's the most ridiculous move I've ever
seen it's not good and I don't know why
they made it but it ends with Justin log
in Justin Long in an aquarium like as if
he he's just like a it's his body is
stitched to a bunch of garbage to make
him look like a walrus and his Jaws
broken and his legs are bent and they
put him in an aquarium like he's happier
and they throw him fish it's like dude
he's still a human like you give him a
cheeseburger it's watched Google it I
think it's called Tusk I'm not sure can
I change my answer yeah I would be a
chicken I'd go to chicken City there you
go oh bro you know you'll be pooping out
eggs all day that's a hen you're gonna
be a rooster rooster I'd be a rooster
but I like eggs too I mean whatever
nasty dude
chicken City man we gotta we're gonna
build a new chicken City at the at the
new space it's gonna be bigger and
better than ever
and then we're gonna build a special uh
you know uh what is it called when
you're like no no what is it called when
you're the king but then you abdicate
your throne to like the prince you're
called like something else
Regent the king Regent that's what I
thought it was yeah so Roberto is going
to get his special quarters as the king
Regent and Roberto Jr is the king oh
okay so if Roberto Jr leaves or
something happens to him Roberta will
take over no he's Roberto's like the
retired kid I think that Regency is the
one that's going to take over if
something happens to the leader like in
absentia okay well it's like when the
king passes thrown down to the prince he
becomes king region or whatever
all right music DC guy says did anyone
ever see the video of the lady at the
chicken farm talking about it and then a
guy behind her takes chicks and puts
them down the grinder shoot oh no no but
yeah it sounds brutal
so maybe you don't want to be a chicken
Space Age gamer says meat chickens are
selectively bred to be ready in like six
to nine weeks after that the legs give
out because they are too fat
yeah man we eat it heart attacks and a
lot of them are genetically modified
altered you know creatures that don't
resemble what they came from when when
you go to like KFC and order a drumstick
and it's like this big or there's like
an Irish place nearby here and I order
the the chicken legs they're like this
big I look over at my chickens and I'm
like not a single one of those things
has legs that big like where do these
things come from we just got some Jersey
Giants they're a couple months old now
and they're gonna get massive and I
don't even know if their legs are gonna
get that big it's like these these
chicken legs you get these are like
Mutant Chickens man this is not a nice
life my wife from Delaware is where I'm
going uh in two days and
um it's chicken farms that's all that
Delaware is chicken farms and you poke
your head in one of those things it's a
miserable life for these chickens I like
the industrial kind of yeah I mean it's
dark they didn't ever see the sunlight
and then they you know yeah they're dead
in six weeks right they pump them full
of hormones they can't walk
they sit somebody somebody said you can
fold a 20 bill you if you fold a 20 bill
you can see 911 if you fold the blue
hundred you can see a missile causing a
tsunami
where how interesting yeah show us
pictures yeah I need to look up how to
do that no I'm like I'm looking at the
100 and I'm like
wear it on the back like if you fold it
on the bag how do you do it do you make
a flex yeah
that's a flex well I mean it's in my
wallet I just have it yeah I read my
wallet 100 bill just keep a stack on the
table yeah I remember the 911 thing but
I haven't seen it did you look it up
yeah I found it but it doesn't really
look that well does it say it what does
it say what does it claim it's causing a
tsunami yeah
how do you do it well that's ridiculous
that's not real that's creative thinking
looks like it's been around since
2013. decoded the tsunami claim yeah
really uh new 100 Bill reveals tidal
wave to hit New York City watch a
YouTube video oh that proves it yeah
evidence Simpsons did it yes did it all
right camel of the Mojave says Authority
and responsibility go hand in hand the
moment you separate them is the moment
your system is going to fall apart
I hear you man
TW rated says Tim you are wrong about
the price to be smuggled across the
border it's around fifteen thousand I
talked to these people wow I've heard
that too I've heard that too so yeah it
sounds sounds right you know
Ruby Romaine says I seriously considered
moving to Florida but I don't want to
deal with hurricanes every year
we were I was in uh when when I was in
Florida there was a scare I think but it
like never got close and then I remember
I actually flew down when one of the big
hurricanes was supposed to come and then
it turned away and went the other
direction so you're in Tampa I mean
you're basically what happened with the
floor with the hurricane just recently
it was supposed to be a direct hit on
Tampa instead it went South went to
Naples Fort Myers kind of like the area
where it ingressed and it sucked all the
water out of Tampa Bay what that was
great go down to Tampa Bay 20 feet of
water should be there you I went and I
walked down on the Barnacles and you
just walk right if it was if it was uh
Nevada or Chicago there'd be bodies
everywhere right skulls and everything
if this was the East River but it's not
uh and so it was just Barnacles it was a
little um you know Crustaceans down
there and so you could walk on Tampa Bay
it was insane what was happening is all
that water was being pulled out of the
bay and shoved on Shore in Fort Myer uh
devastating those I mean obviously
everyone saw the footage but just
flattened those communities and so you
know it's a big you know obviously huge
huge issue but to to this commenter who
said this about uh the hurricanes in
Florida no number one Tampa hasn't had a
direct if you lived in Tampa there's not
been a direct hit hurricane in over 100
years so I guess you can roll your dice
uh when it comes to that and then two if
you're not on you know if you're not
directly on the coast it's these little
Coastal communities because there's all
these little Islands right that get
created and then the hurricane comes
through and literally reforms the land
it's insane so it splits Islands in two
it makes new islands like there's a
there's multiple islands along the
coastline just get created by her oh
that's Charlie that did that it's wild
stuff man sort of like rip the Dirt away
and form new waterways right so there's
places you can boat now there's like a
little there's a bar there's a bar I
cannot remember which island it is and I
was there a couple of months ago the bar
yeah uh in the middle of an island that
was bought off by like three people for
like ten thousand dollars I forgot the
name of it too
um but it's pretty cool it was pretty
fun being there it's named after the
hurricane that created in the island
yeah oh wow you ever go to stealth
Seville in Miami
I do not go to Miami very much so they
built right like off the coast in I
guess it's international waters these
buildings on stilts because the water's
only a few feet deep way out it's crazy
I went out there with this dude and you
need I think it's sonar on a on your
boat to map the Rocks underneath because
the water seriously is like three feet
high at some points but you're like 10
miles out it's crazy you can see the
city in the distance and then you're
looking down you can see huge rocks wait
so is the city a free city is it like
not a nature it's just a few Nations it
was like it was like speakeasies back in
the day where you could go out and
Gamble and do whatever you wanted and
then they were damaged in the 90s and
Hurricane Andrew I think it was and so
now people go there and party and stuff
there's a bar in aquitos in Peru that I
well I didn't actually go uh but it
floods every night when the river Rises
when it comes in and people so it comes
up to your waist while you're drinking
at the bar they were like it's dangerous
are they like fish in there and stuff I
don't know I don't know that'd be nuts
yeah probably yeah and Florida something
would eat you that's for sure piranhas
yeah yeah I agree you see the shark that
came on my there's a shark that was like
washed ashore and was eating someone's
pet oh my gosh yeah there's a shark like
eating someone's pet jeez Santa Claus
says Ian X candy
oh yeah let's have him on the show man
Ian I know I know that's why I said the
wrong thing what's his name Richard
Ibraham Kennedy is that his first name
uh is it Henry Henry Henry Henry Henry
Ibraham Kennedy not sure so my name is
like Henry Henry Henry Smith or
something Henry Smith Henry come on the
show took his wife's last name is that
what he did yeah he did really it was
candy yep oh Candy's a cooler last name
than whatever soy yeah soy pure soy
all right andresco says Tim I'm an
entrepreneur sociologist and former
Professor a recent heart attack created
an urgency to work for greater good
again I've sent a resume CB video intro
outlining my skills hope to hear back as
I have a lot to offer thank you
appreciate it
um I want to take a look we have a
massive library of of emails
unfortunately so and we can only hire so
many people I think there's like 30
people here and 32 people like five
contractors so we certainly can't hire
everybody
musically assured destruction says Alex
Jones talked about the weather machines
years ago
that he did what are they harp is that
what everyone thinks harpson what is in
Alaska yeah a high altitude I'm not sure
what it stands for something radio high
altitude
audio
yeah keep going it's high frequency
active auroral research program and I
think they're what they're supposedly
doing is beaming radio frequency out of
space
um but they're like beaming it out into
space according to them but people think
that they're actually also beaming
things back at us and and experimenting
I don't know have you studied that stuff
much not not too much to be honest oh
man I just I just I see some right here
Ian just got owned semper Ive says white
is a color not a Race So at best it's
okay to be white is a colorful statement
not a racist one boom roasted well if
we're talking facts white as a shade not
a color but you're the one who's always
saying you're not white you're pink so
therefore if white is not a race then
saying it's okay to be white isn't
racist and use on yourself it's black
and white not racist wreck boom wrecked
roasted technically there there's the
human race is like One race isn't it
anyway
I have no it's like one species I don't
I think there's like one
I don't know what the genomics of it are
descent says DW reporting Japanese told
to take cover after NK missile launched
good thing Harris he announced our
allyship with them Ian rolling the ones
on racism
yeah what's going on I saw that I saw
people were commenting about North Korea
firing missiles over Japan or something
I saw that before the show but it looks
like it didn't hit anything and just
kind of went over them yeah but still
yeah that's crazy
well
all right Brian Fields says Tim if the
armorer on the set had the weapon loaded
with our product these dummies that
accident would not have been able to
happen tell your audience check out our
dummy rounds
well yes I guess the issue was there
were dummy rounds and someone put a real
bullet in there so
Rebels that a cause says Joe Rogan had a
joke in the height of Iraq war about
carpet bombing with clouds of chronic
smoke
I mean it's a joke but why not
just blanket cities with dense marijuana
smoke the dosage right yeah yeah just
Stone everybody out of their minds
Gareth green says that is not what a
regent is a regent is someone who
fulfills the Monarch's responsibilities
when they are incapacitated Ian was
correct oh yeah and they could be
appointed
hmm
John Savage's fun fact it's illegal to
wear a ski mask in Florida it's a second
degree misdemeanor from back in 1951
when the state was fighting against the
clan and bank robbers wow I didn't know
that you learned something new every day
YouTube's giving us the business for
some reason it's not loading uh Super
Chips properly oh no yeah I don't know
why it's like frozen oh well we'll grab
uh we'll grab one more I guess because
that's all that's all it's showing oh
wait another one
Jonathan Bethke says hey Tim you always
talk about Tom McDonald but I really did
you take a look at Chris Webby
especially his raw thoughts songs he
refuses to sign with a major label and
said created his own that's very very
cool
andresco says I don't want need to be
hired I'm financially good with my
businesses just use my usable skills and
experience please thanks again we'll
take a look
all right let's grab we'll grab one more
right here from amtru who says white is
the absence of color black is all colors
in pigment uh but in light white is all
color and black is the absence of light
yeah it's a Pink Floyd cover right it's
all the colors go down in the white
prism white light breaks and
all right everybody if you haven't
already but you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you really
do like it many people have been saying
YouTube's not sending notifications so
you know we did we told you guys to be
the notifications you want to see from
YouTube so share the videos If you think
YouTube is playing dirty games and you
want to help fight back we're about a
month away from a midterm and if you
think the conversations are important we
could use your assistance you can follow
the show at timcast you can follow I'm
sorry Tim guest IRL you can follow me at
timcast we're gonna have that members
only show coming up in at about 11 over
at timcast.com so sign up smash that
like button Benny do you want to shout
anything out
uh yes uh shout out to
um yes it gives a gauche to shout out
our our YouTube channel is growing and
which is at the top uh linked here and
thank you very much and we're working
hard on it and what is the channel Benny
Johnson Link in the description the link
in the description yep
um the YouTube King here and it's an
honor to be here it's amazing I've been
trying to respond to people in the in
the super in in just the chats and so a
lot of people saying punch Ian I've seen
that no any hit Ian for us says Adam
Gilbert day uh Brave Dave says yo Benny
punch Ian for all of us I'm not a
violent person and and that is wrong I
do have a question for Ian have you ever
met a white person like a person who
character have you ever met a person
that's this color no I know an albino
black dude which is a mind what does
that mean Victor Varnado what's up my
privilege like what's going on uh I
guess in some if people don't know he's
black but I mean because he's out
perfectly like white skin like whiter
than me yeah blonde hair you got white
hair he's bald but I I don't know what
color his hair would be but I mean his
features look like you can tell he's got
African-American you know some sort of
DNA if you study his speeches
fascinating though and to answer your
question no I've never met a human that
is white I've never met a human that is
black as uh the only person of color
here you should definitely go to my
YouTube channel which is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I made a
video that is pretty interesting about
the situation in Ukraine I made a joke
about the Kardashians and Pelosi's
bazungas since everyone in the chat room
I'm very proud of that joke since
everyone in the chat room is asking for
the bazunkas you could get your bazunka
fix right now on youtube.com forward
slash we are change hope to see you
there thank you so much for having me I
got something for you Lou oh
that was really fun thanks for coming
back oh this was awesome I've been such
a huge fan of this channel I'm gonna say
we're sitting there watching before the
show my wife calls me to say good night
you know and the kids are on there and
you know she texted me she's like are
you Tim pool can I say Adam
because we've just been big fans of this
but more importantly the audience the
community here the audience in the
community is just unbelievable and the
power of just common sense conversation
and normal conversation with people who
maybe have uh diverging World Views is
so important and you're like the only
guy doing it and so I just thank the
audience and obviously everybody here
Community here it's it's important to
like sit around and laugh with other
people laughter creates a Cascade of
serotonin in your brain and like makes
you a happier person it makes you
connected with the people around you
it's healthy it's a healing thing to
laugh with people and laugh at each
other and I laugh at yourself so it's
good that there's a amazing that there's
a show that does this and so that's why
I've been just a huge fan of this
community for such a long time
appreciate it man I only regret we
didn't talk about Bros uh maybe we can
get deep into what's up
if there was a gay bomb everyone would
have seen I know see we're leading into
it exactly anyway yeah I'm looking
forward to talking about that movie that
is a very interesting Saga you guys can
follow me on Twitter and minds.com it's
our petchlitz as well as Sour Patch
let's dummy we will see you all over at
timcast.com sign up become a member
support our work and we'll see you all
there